bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur Public Sénat le Sénat
persiste et signe hier il a rejeté à
nouveau en seconde lecture par 185 voix
contre 137 l'article 2 du projet de loi
défendu par Manuel Vals le ministre de
l'Intérieur et qui visait à mettre en
place un scrutin binom paritaire une
innovation qui devait permettre d'élire
un binôme hommefemme par canton et qui
devait entrer en œuvre lors des
prochaines élections cantonales en 2015
il l'avait déjà rejeté en janvier en
première lecture puis avant-hier en
commission il faut dire que ce scrutin
inédit rencontre l'hostilité du groupe
UMP et des centristes qui refuse toute
idée de parité imposée et surtout sa
conséquence le redécoupage des cantons
puisque deux élus par circonscription
impose de réduire leur nombre par deux
les communistes et les écologistes eux
récl un scrutin de liste à la
proportionnelle le texte qui a été
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale le 26
février devrait donc en toute logique
être rejeté et devenir ainsi le 6e
projet gouvernemental retoqué par le
Sénat mais sans plus tarder retour sur
le rejet du scrutin binominal paritaire
très bonne matinée à tous sur Public
Sénat
monsieur le ministre mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la séance est
ouverte le compre rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué il n'y
a pas d'observation le procèsverbal est
adopté sous les réserves d'usage
monsieur le Président du Sénat a reçu de
Monsieur le Premier Ministre en
application de l'article 67 de la loi
numéro
2004343 du 9 décembre 2004 de
simplification du droit le rapport sur
la mise en application de la loi numéro
1978 du 28 décembre 2011 de finan
rectificatif pour
2011 le rapport a été transmis à la
commission sénatoriale pour le contrôle
et l'application des lois et pour
information la commission des finances
actes et données du dépôt de ce rapport
il est disponible au bureau de la
distribution l'ordre du jour appelle la
suite du projet de loi modifié par
l'Assemblée nationale relatif à
l'élection des conseillers
départementaux des consillers municipaux
et des délégués communautaires et
modifiant le calendrier électoral dans
la discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus au sein de l'article 2 à l'avis
de la commission sur les amendements
numéro 178 rectifié à 116 faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole pour donner l'avis de la
commission sur ses
amendements merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers cèges
collègu nous avons 19 amendements vous
me permettrez de ne pas revenir sur
chacun d'entre eux mais de les parcourir
pour donner la position de notre
commission sur l'amendement numéro 178
rectifié de Monsieur Moré nous sommes
défavorables car on ne peut pas
maintenir le scrutin uninominal à deux
tours aujourd'hui en
vigueur ensuite les amendements numéro
723 et 73 de Madame assassine
les numéros 115 106 104 et 116 de
Monsieur lip de Madame lipiè pardon
madame numéro 60 rectifié bis de
Monsieur Savin le numéro 206 rectifié de
Monsieur Colomba et sa conséquence le
numéro 207 le numéro 130 rectifié TER de
monsieur Dubois et le numéro 177
rectifié de Monsieur Moré ont reçu un
avis défavorable car ils introduisent
sous diverses formes une part de
proportionnel dont la Commission a
estimé qu'elle ne favorisait pas
nécessairement la proximité des
conseillers départementaux avec leur
territoire et leurs électeurs
conformément à l'article 1er bis
certaines propositions méritent
toutefois de les garder à l'esprit
notamment celle de Monsieur
Colomba l'article numéro 11 de monsieur
pointerau a également reçu un avis
défavorable car le scrutin mixte ne
paraît pas une solution pertinente
surtout reposant sur les EPCI il en est
de même de l'amendement numéro 18 de
Monsieur Boyer les amendements numéro 7
TER Mons Nami et 166 monsieur sidau
identique ont reçu un avis favorable car
il supprime une précision qui relève
plutôt du domaine réglementaire par
ailleurs il convient de laisser la
souplesse aux élus de fait l'amendement
de Monsieur daer le numéro 195 rectifier
bis n'a plus lieu d'être dès lors qu'on
supprime la mention selon laquelle n nom
des titulaires apparaissent sur le
bulletin par ordre alphabétique il
n'apparaît plus opportun de prévoir la
même règle pour les suppléants d'où un
avis
défavorable les amendements quasiment
identiques de Monsieur yest numéro 49
rectifié de Monsieur Le Cerf numéro 89
ont reçu un avis favorable sur le
découpage des nouveaux cantons en
section voilà monsieur le Président la
position de la Commission sur ces
différents amendements
voz merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre avis du
gouvernementieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs même avis
même si je vais pas rentrer évidemment
dans
les détails mais pour toutes les raisons
qui ont déjà
eu fourni beaucoup
d'explication si nous proposons ce mode
de scrutin ça n'est pas pour en rester
au au statut quo et si nous proposons un
mode de scrutin qui permet à la fois
l'ancrage territorial et la parité ça
n'est pas
pour épouser des modes de scrutins qui
sont par ailleurs intéressants que nous
connaissons sur d'autres élections de
liste soit dans le cadre
départemental soit dans un autre cadre
territorial donc n'acceptons pas ces
modes de scrutin de liste à la
proportionnelle nous avons examiné avec
intérêt les modes de scrutin mixes avec
une part de scrutin majoritaire et une
part
proportionnelle je tiens à dire que dans
un un certain nombre de départements la
part
proportionnelle conduit à une
représentation infime des minorités par
ailleurs au-delà de l'aspect
constitutionnel mais pas rentrer dans ce
débat il nous semble qu'on gagnerit pas
en clarté et c'est pour cela Mesdames et
Messieurs que le
gouvernement demande le rejet de ces
différents amendements t merci Monsieur
le Ministre y y a-t-il des je vais
mettre au voix les amendement monsieur
Berry de bas vous avez la parole pour
explication de
vote sur l'amendement 178 rectifié
présenté par Monsieur Moret euh non don
j'attends c'est cel de Monsieur poau
d'accord alors je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement 178 rectifié présenté par
Monsieur Maé qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté amendement numéro 72 de madame
assassie qui est pas de demande
d'explication de vote qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
amendement numéro 115 de madame Li pietz
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
amendement numéro 60 rectifié bis de
Monsieur Savin avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
amendement 106 de Madame lipetz avec
deux avis défavorables qui est pour qui
est contre il n'est pas adopté
amendement 206 rectifié de Monsieur
Coloma avec pardon monsieur mzard pour
explication de
vote
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues oui je souis
développer une explication de vote sur
l'amendement présenté par notre
excellent collègue Pierre
Colomba je crois que Pierre Colomba a
raison mais manifestement il a raison
trop
tôt parce que
l'avenir de la collectivité
départementale complètement déconnecté
des
intercommunalité je ne crois pas que ce
soit l'avenir
et l'amendement présenté par Pierre
Colomba a le
mérite de préfigurer ce qui devrait être
demain la solution de
sagesse on nous dit que le binô est un
moyen moderne de résoudre le problème de
la représentation dans les conseils
départementaux je
crains que le provisoire qui en sortira
durera trop longtemps parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous voyons tous sur le
terrain que nos intercommunalité se
développe qu'elles ont de plus en plus
le rôle de Dam le territoire et qu'il
est évident que les déconnectés encore
plus de l'échelon départemental ce n'est
certainement pas
l'avenir
or la méthode et le mécanisme proposé
par pierreive Colomba permettait et
permet à la
fois d'avoir l'avantage les avantages
d'un système proportionnel sans en avoir
les inconvénients
c'est-à-dire qu'on a un système qui
permet de conserver le lien avec le
territoire en calant sur une ou
plusieurs intercommunalités il y a une
logique et une véritable logique
d'aménagement du territoire ça a été
balayé d'un trait alors monsieur le
président de la commission des lois je
vois que ça vous intéresse beaucoup mais
nous avons bien compris que tout que
tout serait balayé vous nous avez
expliqué hier qu'il y avait eu un
travail considérable de la commission
j'y ai peu participer parce que je
reprendrai les arguments qui ont été
justement développés par iian
Assassi les méthodes utilisées
c'est-à-dire la rapidité je sais tout le
travail qu'a fait le rapporteur
oui il n'en reste pas moins que réaliser
cela dans les délais qui ont été imposés
alors que vous nous avez expliqué
vous-même que vous avez réussi à gagner
24 heures pour que nous puissions
déposer des amendements
au moment où l'Assemblée nationale
votait je crois pas que ce soit de bonne
méthode je sais que si elles avaient
utilisé et si elles avaient été
utilisées par le gouvernement précédent
il y a un an vous auriez été le premier
à vous insurger contre ces méthodes
voilà quelle est la réalité alors de
grâce qu'on ne vienne pas nous dire
qu'il a eu un énorme travail c'est vrai
en peu de temps mais qu'il a permis de
faire avancer le dossier alors il y a
des propositions qui ont été faites par
les uns par les autres par aussi no nos
excellents collègues du Parti socialiste
et et ont Balit d'un revers de main
comme si c'était ubuses que original et
cetera alors que moi j'en suis convaincu
ce n'est pas le système d'avenir système
d'avenir c'est d'avoir une une cohérence
entre les collectivités une
complémentarité sans que ce soit une
tutelle des unes sur les autres et bien
on nous a Monsieur le Ministre indiqué
qu'il fallait sortir d'un système qui
pour l'essentiel remoné à 1801 mais vous
savez les systèmes qui
durent les systèmes qui durent montre
qu'ils ont été réfléchis je ne suis pas
sûr que le système que vous nous
proposez il
durera merci monsieur le Président je
vais monsieur le Président de la
Commission vous avez la
parole monsieur le le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues euh à la
suite des propos tenus par notre
collègue Jacques
mard je me permettrai à mon tour de lui
dire quelques
mots
d'abord j'ai dit hier qu'il y avait une
cohérence parmi tous les
collègues qui prenaient la
proportionnelle je l'ai dit je l'ai dit
à Monsieur Colomba qui a proposé un
dispositif dans lequ il y a une
proportionnelle non pas départementale
mais sur des secteurs au sein du
département c'est un choix possible et
monsieur mzard je respecte ce choix
simplement nous sommes un certain nombre
ici avoir fait un autre choix qui est
également pertinent il n'y a pas
irrespectable il n'y a pas ici une
guerre de religion ou de tranchée nous
savons très bien qu'il y a trois
éléments qui doivent être pris en
compte premièrement le rapport au
territoire deuxièmement la juste
représentation politique et enfin la
parité il n'y a pas de hiérarchie entre
ces critères et il est difficile de
trouver la formule idéale qui rassemble
les trois critères donc chacun fait des
propositions il est tout à fait évident
que la proposition de la proportionnelle
qui a des avantages
elle n'est pas approuvée par nombre de
nos collègues présidents de conseil
généraux et conseillers généraux ils
peuvent en témoigner ici surtous les
bancs parce qu'ils tiennent fortement à
l'ancrage territorial du conseiller
départemental voilà à partir de ce
moment-là un choix a été fait en
mesurant les avantages et les
inconvénients et le choix qui a
rassemblé le gouvernement et un certain
nombre des sénateurs pas tous c'est
l'idée de mettre en place la parité sur
une base territoriale voilà donc on
maintient la base territoriale il y a la
parité il y a bien entendu la
représentation politique il n'y a pas
les avantages que donnerait par ailleurs
la proportionnelle qui par ailleurs
entraînerait un certain nombre
d'inconvénients excusez-moi de dire deux
fois par ailleurs voilà premier point
deuxièmement quant à nos méthodes de
travail Monsieur Jacques mzard je
conviens avec vous que la commission des
lois est soumise à rue despreuves car
nous nous travaillons sur une dizaine de
textes en même temps mais je dois vous
faire observer il est inutile que je le
fasse qu'il y a une
constitution qui permet au gouvernement
d'inscrire des textes et que d'autre
part nos groupes parlementaires ont la
faculté d'inscrire des textes dans les
créneaux qui leur sont réservés et que
il y a 15 jours en une seule semaine
quatre groupes ici présents ont chacun
présenté une proposition de loi qui a
été soumise à la commission des lois si
bien que pendant une semaine nous étions
tout le temps en séance mais c'est
l'effet de nos
institutions et enfin par rapport à la
dernière remarque que vous avez faite
monsieur
mard vous avez tout à fait raison sur le
fait que un texte a été adopté le mardi
soir par l'Assemblée national c'est vrai
il était prévu par la Conférence des
Présidents votre groupe vous êtes
représenté vous êtes présent il était
prévu que les amendements devaient être
déposés pour le vendredi
précédent et j'ai pris la décision après
vous avoir entendu avoir entendu un
certain nombre de nos collègues de
déplacer non pas au samedi non pas au
lundi mais au mardi à midi cont tenu du
fait que la Commission avait lieu le
lendemain matin à 9h et qu'il il ne
pouvait en être autrement
nos administrateurs et notre rapporteur
ont dû travailler dans des conditions
qui ont été un peu rudes donc voilà les
mises au point que je voulais faire en
vous disant que je comprends tout à fait
ce que vous dites monsieur mzard et
qu'il n'y a pas de de conflit entre nous
bien
entendu merci monsieur le Président je
vais mettre au voix l'amendement 206
rectifié de monsieur colamba qui a reçu
deux avis défavorables qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté amendement 11
oui
comment il n'est pas
adopté amendement 11 rectifié bis
présenté par Monsieur Poro qui a eu deux
avis explication de vote monsieur Poro
oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
monsieur le monsieur le
ministre hier hier soir lorsque nous
avons discuter de de cet
amendement avant avant de discuter de
ces amendements monsieur le ministre
nous disait qu'il n'y avait pas eu ici
dans cette
assemblée de majorité pour le conseiller
territorial
oui que il n'y avait pas eu de qu'il n'y
a pas de majorité pour la première
lecture pour le scrutin binominal que
nous n'avons pas de majorité pour un
scrutin à la
proportionnelle dans cette i également
et moi je je vous ai proposé donc ce
scrutin mixte à la fois donc
proportionnel dans le cadre des
agglomérations et au scrutin majorité à
à deux tours dans le dans les zones
rurales je crois qu'il correspond tout à
fait à à la volonté de mettre en place
de la proximité euh de la parité
faciliter la parité puisque c'est
c'était l'objectif de la favoriser la la
la la parité puisque c'était l'objectif
de la Constitution et puis à la fois de
de mettre en place et non pas d'imposer
la parité c'est ça c'est tout à fait le
le terme exactement que nous avons
employé hier et puis en même
tempstion c'est la Constitution que nous
avons voté donc c'était un c'est un
spécificité que nous pourrions mettre en
place que nous aurions pu discuter et
j'entendais même hier monsieur pierive
Colomba qui nous disait regretter le
conseiller
territorial je si
ouais mais enfin que c'était que c'était
finalement que c'était mieux donc on
voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui finalement le conseiller
territoriale n'était pas n'était pas une
mauvaise chose donc je va vous
sauver je je maintiens je maintiens ce
scrutin dont on aura on aurait pu bien
sûr discuter et on on l'a évoqué lors
des états généraux on voit bien que ce
que nous avons discuté lors des états
généraux on n'a pas retenu
grand-chose au niveau de cette de cette
loi je le TR très sincèrement puisque ce
ce scrutin
binominal qui est un scrutin hybride
dont on avait dit que le conseiller
territorial était aussi un scrutin
hybride et bien là on va aller vers un
couple infernal avec le le scrutin
binominal je crois que vous verrez ça
sera un couple infernal vous le verrez à
l'usage si malheureusement ce scrutin ce
scrutin
continuez mon cher cèguez oui donc je je
souhaite réitérer donc mon souhait avec
mes collègues qui ont Cigné cet
amendement et bien de voter cet
amendement qui permettrait de de sortir
de cette crise que nous avons au sein de
cet hémicycle et qui permettrait à la
fois la parité le pluralisme et la
proximité très bien merci Monsieur
poinau pour explication de vote la
parole à Monsieur ber de
oui à l'inverse de Monsieur pointerau je
voudrais dire toute mon hostilité au
type de scrutin qu'il propose parce que
sous son air patelin qu'est-ce qu'il
défend en fort en fait il défendent tout
simplement la primauté la primauté du
milieu rural sur le milieu urbain et
cette primauté elle n'est pas exclue
comme l'aurait dit mon excellent
collègue jean-Jacques Mirassou derrièurs
penser voilà ça c'est le premier point
le deuxème point vous partez du constat
qu'il y a deux types de conseillers
généraux ou demain deux types de
conseillers départementaux les premiers
sont des conseillers urbains dont dans
les conseillers urbains obligatoirement
il faut qu'il y ait de la proportionnel
et dans l'autre nous avons des de la
proportionnel et de la parité et dans
les autres nous restons sur le statut co
avec ce que l'on connaît jusqu'à
aujourd'hui euh puisque ça a été
démontré à la fois par le travail de
notre rapporteur et ça a été rappelé par
notre ministre les résultats des
dernières élections euh des conseils
généraux ne montrent un recul de la
parité bon donc c'est le statut co avec
pour arrièrepenser d'agranger un certain
nombre de positions qui sont établis
aujourd'hui euh dans la France plus
rurale qu'urbaine
non non pas du tout pas du tout je
voudrais dire aussi que nous avions
évoqué parce que certains ont fait
référence à la mission bot où je
participais aussi et ça a été évoqué
mais ça n'a pas été retenu monsieur
pointerau pour un certain nombre de
raisons qui ont été démontrées y compris
cellees-là parce que faire deux systèmes
en disant l'urbain euh ben voilà c'est à
la proportionnelle et le rural c'est au
scrutin un nominal euh c'est pas très
bon deuxièmement dans votre proposition
euh vous êtes vous vous mettez un
plafond à 500000 habitants pour les
communautés de communes et vous dites il
ne pourrait y avoir il y aura deux
représentants ça ça écrase encore au
moins non mais ça écrase encore plus la
différence qui peut y avoir entre le
milieu rural et le milieu urbain un
problème de taille et un problème de
statut compte tenu de la spécificité euh
des communes ou des cantons dans lequel
on est représenté bon je voudrais quand
même le rappeler personne n'est dupe
mais je suis contre le système et
beaucoup avec moi le son donc je tenais
à le souligner monsieur pointerau merci
mon cher collègue plus de demande de
prise de
parole monsieur Mirassou
oui non pas en cause monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues notre
collègue parl tout à l'heure d'él
hybride faisant une référence au
conseiller territorial quand vous
expliquez la possibilité et la
compatibilité au niveau d'un conseiller
général d'un conseiller départemental
maintenant de pouvoir être élu soit par
le biais du scrutin proportionnel soit
par le biais de scrutin binominal vous
êtes en train de fabriquer un élu
hybride et je ne comprends pas je ne
comprends pas votre obstination à
vouloir créer un cvage entre les élus
issus du rural et ceux issus du milieu
urbain j'imagine que dans votre
département monsieur pointerau il doit
pas y avoir tellement de communautés
urbaines parce que sinon vous deviez
dialoguer avec les conseillers généraux
issus du milieu urbain et vous verriez
que ce ne sont pas des élus perdus dans
la foule déconnectés de la réalité ne
connaissant pas le monde associatif ne
connaissant pas les leaders d'opinion ne
faisant pas des des des réunions
destinées à faire des cont rendu de
mandat le conseiller général urbain est
un conseiller général à partenère j'en
parle un peu en connaissance de cause et
j'ai la faiblesse de penser que qu'il
soit urbain ou rural il a rigoureusement
la même la même la même légitimité ce
qui vous préoccupe actuellement c'est
parce que vous jouez profil bas ou petit
bras de dire on va essayer de se
bquériser autant que faire ce peu sur le
rural quit abandonner quelque part de
marcher sur le plan électoral dans
l'urbain vous vous trompez et vous avez
une vision passéiste du département
comme jeou ai dit hier soir l'enjeu qui
nous attend dans le cadre d'un scrutin
qui va moderniser cette institution
c'est de faire en sorte que la promotion
du département tout confondu urbain et
rural soit tourné vers le 21e siècle et
c'estes objectif vous avez une vision
passéiste elle n'est pas bonne il est
temps de vous ressaisir merci mon cher
collègue je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement 11 rectifié bis qui a reçu
deux avis défavorables de monsieur
pointerau qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
amendement numéro
73 présenté par Madame kquierman qui a
reçu deux avis défavorables qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
amendement de Madame Lipietz avec deux
avis défavorables qui est pour qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté amendement
130 rectifié TER présenté par Monsieur
roche oui monsieur Dubois vous avez la
parole oui monsieur le Président euh
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
il était temps que j'arrive le train
avec 40 minutes de retard mais bon donc
voà je j'ai mon amendement a été défendu
hier par mon collègue monsieur roche
donc sur le le scrutin mixte euh le le
le le scrutin mixte pourquoi parce que
tout simplement et je pense que ça a été
dit plusieurs fois dans cet hémicycle
euh le le binô avec la division du
nombre de canton par deux on tue tout
simplement les territoires ruraux et il
était assez facile d'imaginer puisque en
ville le conseiller général est un
inconnu puisque en
ville puisque en ville mes chers
collègues mais mais
attendez ne niz pas les évidences ne niz
pas les évidences enfin je dirais on est
il y a de nombreux collègues conseillers
généraux des territoires ruraux ils sont
connus connu par les maires des
territoires par les présidents
d'association des
territoires par les habitants eux-mêmes
en ville le conseiller général est un
illustre inconnu non seulement c'est un
illustre inconnu et en plus de cela les
habitants ne connaissent même pas les
limites de leur territoire cantonal donc
il était évident évident et le comment
caricatural mais pas du tout c'est une
réalité c'est une mais mais mais vous
ignorez pointz la réalité des
territoires ruraux et ça vous arrange
tout simplement de mettre en place ce
système je dirais de vote voilà la
réalité telle qu'elle est ceci étant dit
il était cohérent effectivement pour
gagner en parité de faire en sorte que
la proportionnelle se fasse dans les
villes et non pas dans les campagnes et
que l'on mette en place système
mixte la parole à Monsieur keltenbach
pour explication de vote oui je crois
que le débat a été de qualité on voit
qu'il y a les tenants de la
proportionnelle les tenants du scrutin
nominal avec pour la parité le
binominal c'est vrai qu'il y a pas plus
de femmes sur les band de l'UMP ce matin
qu'ilier voilà c'est un peu c'est un peu
dommage c'est un
signe
end elles ne sont pas présentes
voilà
donc là
c'est s'il vous plaît allez monsieur
Monsieur kaltenb Je laiss j'ai du mal à
m'exprimer monsieur le Président je
laisse l'UMP assumer ces propos j'en
viens au fond qui est des élus
favorables à la proportionnelle
favorable au scrutin uninominal
binominal c'est normal mais que certains
cherchent à instrumentaliser le mode de
scrutin pour dresser les élus ruraux qui
seraient actifs présents indispensables
et les élus urbains qui ne serviraient à
rien je pense qu'il y a un pas que le
sénateur Dubois a franchi qui qui ne va
pas dans le sens du rassemblement de
tous les élu qu'un élu soit élu en zone
rurale ou en zone urbaine il a son rôle
à jouer il est légitime et il a une
grande valeur parce qu'il est aussi
présent sur le terrain pour défendre ses
concitoyens sur les politiques sociales
sur les politiques d'enseignement dans
les collèges et ne ne cherchons pas à
faire croire que l'élu en zone urbaine
ne sert à rien l'élu en zone urbaine est
utile alors
après alors après après bien évidemment
bien évidemment je j'aimerais pouvoir
terminer bien évidemment lorsqu'on a un
petit canton avec 1000 habitants le
conseiller général est connu plus
largement que lorsquen zone urbaine on a
des cantons avec 40000 ou 50000
habitants mais c'est un petit peu ça le
fond du problème c'est vous voulez
défendre un système qui avec des Bours
pourris favorisit les zones rurales vous
le faites soi-disant pour défendre la
ruralité en fait vous ne le faites que
pour défendre vos intérêts politiciens
et électoraux c'est vos élus vousz
défendre personne n'est dupe ne dites
pas que vous défendez la ruralité vous
défendez vos élus qui sont d'ailleurs
qui sont d'ailleurs bien souvent des
hommes preuve sur ces bancs et c'est
pourquoi au fond vous refusez aussi la
parité alors heureusement le débat n'a
pas dérapé je n'ai pas entendu que la
parité était un gadget et que les femmes
étaient des potiges comme en première
lecture mais on voit bien que ce qui
vous gêne c'est la parité vous ne voulez
pas qu'il y ait autant de femmes que
d'hommes élu c'est ce que propose ce
modote de scrutin c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement et le groupe socialiste le
défend c'est au nom de la parité et vous
verrez les résultats cela permettra
d'avoir des assemblées paritaires et ça
permettra de redorer le blason des
départements qui seront en phase avec le
pays et c'est ça aussi laion département
faire en sorte que grâce au vote de
scrutin le département soit en phase
avec la réalité de la France aujourd'hui
donc voilà pour toutes ces raisons il
faut bien sûr rejeter cet amendement qui
n'a que des objectifs politiciens et des
visés électorales allons au fond
défendons la proximité
défend la parité défendons l'égalité
devant le scrutin en adoptant ce mode de
scrutin binominal pour l'élection des
conseillers
départementaux merci la parole à
Monsieur guerot pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je crois qu'on peut
pas laisser dire ce qu'on vient
d'entendre avec autant de de verv et qui
dénature complètement les propos qui ont
été tenu par un de notres collègues
pourquoi parce que moi j'étais
conseiller général dans milieu pendant
17 ans et j'ai pu constater à quel point
cette fonction a forcément du sens et
elle peut être parfaitement concrète
pour autant de considérer que parce
qu'on veut faire évoluer un scrutin à la
proportionnelle transformerait cette
situation en conseil général qui ne
serent à rien ne représente que vos
propos et ne je considérais en la
matière que ce c'est là votre expression
et votre sentiment et certainement pas
le nôtre nous considérons que
effectivement il faut aller vers plus de
parité
comme l'a très bien dit mon collègue
tout à l'heure la problématique de la
densité des territoires en milieu urbain
la difficulté de définir de fait la
limite des territoires en milieu urbain
rend l'identification de celui qui tient
cette fonction beaucoup plus difficile
qu'en milieu rural où chacun connaît
contenu de la taille contenu au
contraire de la facilité qu'il y a de
définir les limites territoriales en
territoire rural on identifie
parfaitement son conseil général moi
même en tant que sénateur lorsque je
vais dans des vœux communaux les
conseillers généraux prendent prennent
la parole et sont parfaitement
identifiés ce qui n'est pas absolument
pas le cas dans les milieux urbains
c'est cette différence qui est un
constat de fait que chacun d'entre nous
peut contrôler au quotidien qui nous
amène à penser qu'il peut y avoir une
logique d'évolution de la loi électorale
en favorisant le scrutin proportionnel
dans une commité d'agglomération urbaine
ou en tout cas dans des villes dans des
secteurs urbains de plus de 100000
habitants en ayant par ailleurs sur le
rural une autre forme de de scrutin
c'est pas une volonté de diviser c'est
une volonté de prendre en considération
des différence fondamental dans
l'organisation de nos territoires et n'y
voyez pas en aucune manière un espèce de
de calcul électoral du même style que
celui que vous cherchez à faire en ce
moment et qui ne trompe personne
merci merci mon cher collègue la parole
à Madame
lip merci monsieur le Président j'avoue
je suis un petit peu choquée d'entendre
cette diichotomie il marqué de cette
diichotomie voà oui je remet excusez-moi
oui je disais que j'étais un peu choqué
d'entendre cette dichotomie qui est
ainsi créé entre les élus des secteurs
ruraux et les élus des secteurs urbains
on avait on a eu un petit peu la même
par rapport aux élus des conseils
régionaux où on a entendu plusieurs fois
que les élus des conseils régionaux
parce que élu sur un scrutin de liste
n'était pas connu lorsque j'ai été
conseillère régionale et que je devais
faire dans ma vaste scènemarne plus de
100 km pour être membre d'une clé d'un
d'un
sage lorsque je m'y suis présenté on m'a
dit ah les conseillers régionaux
existent oui et ils existent la preuve
je l'ai rencontré je crois que tout
simplement il faut se rappeler que nous
sommes chacun a ses priorités lorsque
l'on est élu en conseil régional il y a
d'autres priorités peut-être en conseil
général et que tous les élus n'ont pas
le même rôle ça ça me paraît important
deuxièmement je pense que la réforme t
qu'elle nous est proposée et même encore
une fois si les veres sont
particulièrement et les écologistes sont
particulièrement déçus de ce qui nous
est proposé aura au moins un mérite
comme on l'a rappelé il y a même pas 2
minutes nous serons nous allons nous
rapprocher des territoires pour ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui élus dans des cantons
totalement inconnaissables parce que
plus de 40 50000 électeurs c'est
absolument impossible en revanche
lorsque vous allez dans les petits
cantons il suffit simplement de faire
une campagne électorale dans les petits
cantons moi je l'ai fait dans la dans le
canton de mes ancêtres à la fin de la
campagne électorale tout le monde me
connaissait quand j'y retourne encore
aujourd'hui on me dit ah ben oui vous
avez été la candidate pour les dernières
cantenales donc c'est uniquement un
problème de nombre de d'électeurs et non
pas un problème de personnes de
conseiller cantonal enfin pardon
conseiller départemental c'est pourquoi
je pense que notre réforme va un
apporter un rapprochement
électeur élu et ça déjà ça sera on le
connaîtra mieux et deuxièmement fait
œuvre d'instruction
civique parce que lorsqu'on a changera
le nom lorsqu'on a changé le nom et
qu'on a dit décidé qu'il s'appelait
conseiller départemental ah bien là ça
va faire tilte les gens vont dire ah
benah oui le conseiller départemental
c'est celui qui s'occupe du RMI c'est
celui qui s'occupe de l'ER alors là ça
sera pas tellement mieux mais il y aura
donc un rapprochement l'instruction
civique va se mettre en marche
naturellement et je crois que les
reproches qui sont fait aujourd'hui qui
sont non seulement totalement
injustifiés sert encore moins justifiés
demain merci merci ma chère collègue
monsieur Favier a la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vrais
également à mon tour dire mon désaccord
avec ce double mode de scrutin
différencié entre les zones rurales et
les zones urbaines pour ma part si nous
sommes effectivement favorables au mode
proportionnel nous ne pouvons pas
accepter effectivement que le en zone
rurale on pourrait s'exonérer d'un mode
de scrutin qui ne tendrait pas
effectivement à la parité ce devoir de
parité il doit être général sur
l'ensemble du territoire et pas
simplement effectivement en zone urbaine
et par ailleurs je crois que pour ceux
qui ont l'expérience effectivement des
élus en zone urbaine je crois que la
caricature qui nous a été présentée de
considérer que les élus de milieu urbain
seraient des inconnus vis-à-vis de leur
population c'est quelque chose de tout à
fait inacceptable j'invite simplement
nos collègues qui éventuellement
connaissent mal cette réalité là de
venir évidemment par exemple ici en
région parisienne où les conseillers
généraux sont parfaitement effectivement
en lien avec leur population tout dépend
évidemment des pratiques des uns ou des
autres mais ils sont en lien avec la vie
associative ils sont en lien
effectivement avec ils représentent leur
département dans les collèges ils
participent aux actions de développement
de l'emploi partout et ils sont en
général parfaitement connus deuxièmement
quel est le rôle parce que la question
c'est pas simplement d'être connu c'est
pas ça qui quel est l'intérêt
effectivement c'est de savoir ce que
font réellement effectivement ces
conseillers généraux à quoi quoi ils
servent est-ce que c'est simplement
d'être reconnu uniquement simplement par
son voisin la question la plus
importante c'est savoir quelle politique
queles sont les politiques qui sont
menées effectivement au plan de ces
départements est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
se bat effectivement pour l'emploi dans
ces départements est-ce que sont est-ce
qu'on se bat pour le logement pour tous
est-ce qu'on se bat pour réduire les
inégalités et ça c'est les politiques
qui sont menées au plan départemental et
elles se font de manière collective avec
l'intervention évidemment de l'ensemble
des conseillers généraux donc voilà
c'est c'est un problème de fond donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
sommes effectivement favorables à une
proportionnelle pourquoi pas d'ailleurs
la proposition de Monsieur Colomba était
intéressante dans le sens compris une
proportionnelle sur la base des
intercommunalités avec malgré tout quand
même une difficulté dans sa mise en
œuvre aujourd'hui c'est que la carte
intercommunale n'a pas été effectivement
achevée c'est notamment vrai par exemple
pour la la petite couronne en région
parisienne et que le temps nécessaire
pour achever cette carte intercommunale
si nous voulons le faire sur la base
d'intercom communalité de projet et pas
simplement d'opportunités politicienne
ça demande du temps ça demande du
travail il faut effectivement que ce
soit des vrais projets de territoire qui
soi portés et je ne suis pas persuadé
que compte tenu des dates de
renouvellement des élections
départementales nous soyons en mesure
forcément d'avoir achevé dans de bonnes
conditions cette carte intercommunale à
cet échance là donc ce qui met
effectivement ce qui fragilise la
proposition d'une proportionnelle
infraat départemental à l'échéance à la
prochaine échéance de renouvellement
mais pour autant effectivement c'est une
piste de travail sur lequel euh je pense
que cette proposition là était
certainement supérieure au projet de
binôme qui nous est aujourd'hui
proposé merci la parole à Monsieur
mzard monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues simplement
un mot monsieur le ministre vous avez
très justement rappelé hier que la voix
du Sénat c'était la voix des
collectivités
locales pour l'instant mais ça a un
intérêt c'est que nous faisons état les
uns et les autres d'expérience locale
personne n'est exemp de d'arrière-pensée
électorale quand même nous avons tous
aussi une longue expérience de la de la
vie politique donc on voit bien les
enjeux y compris sur zones urbaines et
zones rural moi j'ai été élu pendant 14
ans et demi d'un canton
miurbain mi rural vous savez hybride
alors était déjà hybride sans OGM
mais j'en ai tiré une expérience
monsieur le ministre c'est que dans les
neuf communes rurales le canton
correspondait à une
réalité territoriale bon et que les
électeurs connaissaient le canton dans
la partie urbaine ils avaient du mal à
savoir dans quel canton ils
étaient ça c'est la réalité
de terrain ça ne veut pas dire que il ne
faut pas avoir une approche
départementale et c'est ce que chaque
conseiller départemental doit avoir
c'est-à-dire émettre des votes en
fonction de l'intérêt général du du du
département mais il est bon aussi d'être
sur le terrain et
d'entendre les demandes les difficultés
des maires de chaque commune des
associations et cetera mais la réalit
n'est pas la même quand on est dans une
zone très urbaine et quand on est dans
un canton rural et je n'oppose pas les
uns ou les autres c'est une constatation
bon
donc je je crois qu'il est
malheureusement dans le projet que vous
nous
présentez contrairement à ce qu'a dit
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois il y a pas trois objectifs qui
sont égaux le lien avec le territoire
la parité il y a un objectif premier
d'ailleurs je l'entends vous avez un
objectif premier c'est la parité qui
peut qui peut se concevoir mais qui
efface les autres et la difficulté de
votre projet c'est celui-là c'est qu'en
fait il y a un objectif qui surpasse
tous les autres et votre projet se cale
sur cet objectif prioritaire et ça a
effectivement une conséquence sur les
équilibres dans nos territoires voilà
quelle est la réalité alors ensuite
c'était effectivement un choix de fond
politique mais je pense qu'il e été bon
de travailler davantage pour essayer
d'améliorer le système et je regrette
que on a écarté tous les autres
systèmes merci la parole à Monsieur le
Président
zooketo merci monsieur le
Président je voudrais vraiment qu'on
étudie le l'amendement qui a été exposé
par Daniel Dubois et Gérard roche avec
le plus de sérieux possible nous n'avons
pas proposer un dispositif gadget ou
quelque chose qui serait supposé
avantager les uns et les autres
électoralement nous avons réfléchi et
nous n'avons pas la prétention de
proposer quelque chose de de parfait
mais en tout cas quelque chose de
meilleur que le scrutin binominal que
vous voulez nous imposer par la force
pourquoi parce que nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion la semaine dernière de dire
que nous évolons dans un contexte de
crise de la
représentativité regardez ce qui se
passe au élection cantonal dans les
zones urbaines le taux de participation
est de plus en plus bas de temps en
temps il est même dramatiquement bas on
voit des conseillers généraux qui sont
élus à l'occasion d'élection partiell
dans des zones urbaines avec à peine
plus de 10 % de taux de participation
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire lorsqu'on
arrive à une telle situation il est
temps de regarder la réalité en face et
de changer les choses nous voulons des
conseillers départementaux qui
représente les territoires et bien que
cela vous plaise ou non et je parle en
connaissance de cause ayant été
conseiller général d'un territoire
exclusivement urbain le territoire en
ville c'est l'agglomération c'est la
zone urbaine ce n'est pas un quartier de
cette agglomération voire même une
commune de cette agglomération c'est
l'agglomération toute entière et donc
les conseillers départementaux de ces
territoires urbains doivent être élus
dans une circonscription qui comprend le
territoire urbain lui même à partir de
ce moment-là il n'est plus possible de
procéder par un vote au scrutin
uninominal majoritaire on doit utiliser
la proportionnelle et cela se tombe très
bien puisque la proportionnelle permet
de répondre aux soucis que nous avons
d'améliorer la parité sur ce point je
voudrais rappeler que la loi
constitutionnelle nous demande pas
d'assurer violemment brutalement la
parité elle nous demande de favoriser
l'égal accès des hommes et des femmes au
aux fonctions électives et bien voilà ce
que nous proposons avec cet amendement
de prendre en compte la spécificité du
territoire urbain d'améliorer la
représentativité de ces conseillers
départementaux urbains et de favoriser
la parité voilà pourquoi je vous demande
de le voter merci merci monsieur le
Président je ne vois plus de demande
d'explication de vote alors je vais
mettre au voix l'amendement 130 rectifié
terre présenté par Monsieur roche et
Dubois euh qui ont reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour son
adoption qui est
contre l'amendement n'est pas adopté
amendement 179
rectifié de Monsieur Maé pas de demande
d'explication de vote deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté amendement 207
rectifié de Monsieur Colomba avec deux
avis défavorables qui est
pour
qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté amendement 18
présenté par Monsieur Boyer avec deux
avis défavorables qui est pour son
adoption qui est qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté amendement 7
rectifié TER présenté par Monsieur Nami
qui a reçu un avis favorable de la
commission et un avis de rejet du
gouvernement qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre il est adopté
amendement 49
rectifié qui a reçu un avis favorable de
la commission un avis de rejet du
gouvernement présenté par monsieur hiest
qui est pour par qui est contre il est
adopté je ne vous avais pas vu monsieur
Savari je le le vote a eu lieu vous
pouvez prendre la parole maintenant si
vous le souhaitez
oui c'était un amendement effectivement
sur les sections de cont nous ont
soutenu pour justement montrer la
difficulté dans dans dans les zones
rurales dans mon département le
département de la mar nous j'ai une
moyenne de 52 habitants au kilomè Carr
en moyenne générale j'ai des zones à 7
habitants au au kilomètre Carr ce qui
fait que pour regrouper les cantons
ruraux qui étaient peut-être certes en
grand nombre on peut pas dire que ce
n'était pas égalitaire bien
entendu pour les regrouper il faut
quatre à 5 cantons là où j'ai quatre
conseillers généraux ruraux il y aura
deux conseillers gén un homme et une
femme en milieu urbain parond les
cantons étaient nettement plus
équilibrés sur le plan de la population
comme partout et quand on a une
agglomération comme rince qui représente
la moitié du département là où il y
avait un conseiller général urbain il y
aura deux conseiller départementaux un
homme une femme urbain donc il y aura
deux fois plus de canton rurbain pour
deux fois moins de canton ruraux c'est
une déstructuration complète du
territoire le département est réaffirmé
dans sa vocation de représenter à la
fois les hommes et les territoires et
àario le mode de scrutin détruit cette
représentation territoriale on réaffirme
la position du département et à contario
on lui donne de moins en moins de moyens
pour exercer ses responsabilités donc
quelle est la position du gouvernement
favorable au département ou destructeur
destructrices vis-à-vis des départements
on est en droit de se poser la question
parce que il y a véritablement pas
d'adéquation entre les propos et les
actes
merciadame
non l'amendement a déjà été voté donc
donc par Monsieur monsieur Savari a été
entendu avant qu'il ait pris la parole
comme quoi c'est quand même quelque
chose de très très fort nous nous
arrivons à l'amendement 195 recéctifier
bis présenté par Monsieur Dallier qui a
reçu deux avis défavorables pas de
demande d'explication de vote qui est
pour son adop alors Monsieur Dalier au
moins cette fois-ci sur le mien monsieur
le Président euh écoutez à partir du
moment où l'amendement précédent a été
adopté pas le dernier mais celui d'avant
je vois pas pourquoi on nadopterait pas
celui-là à faire figurer le nom des
remplaçants sur les bulletins de vote ça
me semble quand même la moindre des
choses ces remplaçants doivent être
connus de la population je comprends pas
bien pourquoi ce cet amendement
oui mais enfin écoutez on décide de
l'ordre alphabétique ou non au travers
d'un d'un amendement précédent on
pourrait adopter
celui-là merci Monsieur Dalier je mets
au voix l'amendement 195 rectifier bis
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
son
adoption qui est contre l'amendement est
adopté
amendement l'amendement 89 de Monsieur
le serf il tombe parce qu'il est
satisfait on est d'accord donc
l'amendement 89 tombe monsieur le
rapporteur voulaz dire d'accord donc
l'amendement est tombé parce que
satisfait amendement numéro 116 présenté
par Madame Lipietz avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre l'amendement
n'est pas adopté je vais mettre au voix
l'article
comment j'ai pas entendu monsieur
Moré prenez le micro je n'entends pas ce
que vous dites excusez je je voulais
faire une explication de vote sur
l'article il me semblait que vous alliez
mettre au voix l'article avant les
explication de vote mais bien sûr que
non ah bon très bien donc comme
d'habitude je vais mettre au voix
l'article 2 donc je mea évidemment je
pense qu'il y aura des explications de
vote donc qui souhaite une explication
de vote monsieur Maé vous avez donc la
parole je vous en remercie infiniment
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues quelques mots pour vous dire
naturellement que je ne voterai pas cet
article 2 vous n'en serez pas étonné
mais j'aimerais surtout euh dire
quelques quelques mots à l'attention du
ministre enfin avant j'aimerais quand
même m'adresser à Monsieur Kaltenbach
parce que j'étais quand même assez
stupéfait de voir qu'il osait dire que
nos amendements sont politiciens c'est
vraiment le pyoman qui crie au feu Vous
soutenez un gouvernement qui se livre au
pire tripatouillage électoral que l'on
nit jamais connu dans l'histoire de la
République j'aimerais que l'on me cite
ici quel autre gouvernement a changé
tous les modes de scrutin en aussi peu
de temps en invoquant chaque fois des
règles différentes pour justifier ces
changements aujourd'hui on nous dit
qu'il faut éviter la proportionnelle
ensuite on nous dira qu'il faut
l'introduire pour les législatives la
développer pour les sénatoriales et la
maintenir pour les régionales où est la
logique à part celle de vouloir à tout
prix échapper à la sanction populaire et
maintenir la main mise sur les
collectivités et les institutions que
vous dirigez alors de grâce au moins ne
nous traitez pas de politicien parce que
c'est vrai que sur le sujet nous sommes
vraiment tout petit devant vous monsieur
Kaltenbach alors monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur vous avez hier déployé
énormément d'énergie pour tenter de
sauver l'article 2 et vous l'avez fait
avec une argumentation que j'ai trouvé
très curieuse vous nous avez dit oui il
y a pas de majorité sur l'article 2 la
preuve vous l'avez rejeté en première
lecture la preuve vous l'avez rejeté en
commission des lois mais il faut quand
même que vous le votiez il vous plaît
pas mais il faut quand même que vous le
votiez parce que le Sénat et la chambre
des collectivités locales et donc elle
doit voter cet article mais nous sommes
pas la chambre d'enregistrement des
collectivités local nous sommes une
chambre délibérative et nous n'avons pas
à voter des articles qui ne nous
plaisent pas et votre démarche elle
aurait dû être tout autre elle aurait dû
être de dire je suis devant l'assemblée
qui représente les collectivités locales
et je vais essayer de trouver avec elle
un mode de scrutin qui lui convienne or
ça n'est pas ce qui a été fait et on
vient de le voir il y a eu 19
amendements pour modifier le mode de
scrutin que vous proposez ils ont tous
été balayés d'un revers de main si vous
aviez voulu trouver une solution il y en
avait soit en accordant un peu de
proportionnel pour faire plaisir à vos
alliés et vous auriez trouvé une
majorité avec vos alliés soit en faisant
un pas en notre direction vous auriez pu
au minimum accepter la proposition de
Monsieur sido qui était de créer des
sections au sein des cantons pour
permettre un ancr territorial plus fort
je suis étonné parce qu'à une époque
vous aviez un autre projet qui était de
dire on maintient les cantons et en
revanche on les regroupe dans des
circonscriptions électorales pour qu'il
y ait cette parité hommes-femme et ça
aurait été un scrutin moins mauvais que
celui que vous proposez au au final donc
finalement vous n'avez fait aucune
avancée la seule chose que vous nous
dites c'est et bien peut-être que si
vous votez ce mode de scrutin on fera un
effort sur le tunnel des plus ou moins
20 pour passer au plus ou moins 30 mais
nous n'avons aucune une assurance sur ce
fait nous avons je suis désolé de le
dire nous avons dans le passé déjà connu
sur des modes de scrutin des marchés de
dupe et donc nous sommes très prudents
sur le sujet et quand je vous ai rappelé
hier que nous avions été étonnés de voir
que sur le seuil applicable pour le
scrutin de liste vous aviez soutenu le
seuil à 1000 et que vous l'aviez laissé
passer à 500 à l'Assemblée vous m'avez
dit ah mais ça c'est pas moi c'est
l'Assemblée nationale donc quelle
garantie avons-nous que ce que vous êtes
prêt dans votre grande bonté à nous
lâcher sur le tunnel plus ou moins 30 %
sera effectivement maintenu à à
l'Assemblée nationale et puis pour
terminer pour terminé je voudrais juste
rappeler vous rappeler monsieur le
ministre que j'ai posé hier des
questions je vous avez posé des
questions auxquelles vous n'avez pas
répondu et comme c'est certainement un
oubli de votre part je vais vous les
rappeler sur le redécoupage quelle
garantie avons-nous par rapport à
l'éventualité de prendre en compte les
cantons actuels est-ce que ce sera un
regroupement dans la mesure du possible
de canton actuel ou où ce sera table
rase on repart avec une paire de ciseaux
à la voglette est-ce qu'on essaiera de
prendre en compte les bassins de vie
pour que les canton a une vraie réalité
est-ce que l'on essaiera dans la mesure
du possible de tenir compte de
l'intercommunalité sur ces points-là
vous ne m'avez pas répondu et vous ne
m'avez pas non plus répondu quant aux
conséquences de ce redécoupage sur
plusieurs milliers de communes qui
allaient perdre leur qualité de
chef-lieu de canton avec ce que ça
implique en terme de perte de dotation
pour des communes déjà très éprouvé oui
monsieur le ministre vous avez l'air de
de prendre ça à la légère mais les
finances des collectivités locales sont
telles avec des dotations qui vont
baisser pour la première fois grâce à ce
gouvernement que les communes qui vont
en plus perdre la dotation de cheflieu
de canton aimeraiit bien au moins éviter
cela je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Moré la parole à
Monsieur
laabbé monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues notre notre
groupe est quelque peu
déçu tout comme d'autres groupes qui ont
fait de gros efforts d'imagination pour
essayer de trouver à la fois la formule
où la o la parité pouvait être pouvait
être
respecté la proportionn la
proportionnelle également et aussi la
représentation territoriale et hélas
cela n'a pas été retenu mais notre
groupe reconnaissant l'avancée apporté
par la parité
mais insatisfait du fait que le mode de
scrutin ne permette pas une juste
représentation politique de manière
automatique va s'abstenir par rapport à
cet article 2 je voudrais rajouter à
titre personnel j'ai cependant moi pris
la décision suite au débat d'hier de
voter pour cet cet article 2 ce scrutin
tout particulier permet la parité qui va
véritablement révolutionner le paysage
politique des départements en permettant
un grand renouveau des assemblées
départemental le morbillant où j'ai
siégé pendant 10 ans compte 42
Conseillers généraux actuellement 36
hommes et 6 femmes va passer à 21 hommes
et 21 femmes le paysage va forcément
changer en ayant en ayant malgré tout
une représentation territoriale assurée
et en tant que conseiller général passé
j'y attache aussi de l'importance le
risque parce qu'il y en a pour certains
ce pourrait d'ailleurs être un calcul le
risque c'est de tendre vers
une bipolarisation politique qui n'est
pas souhaitable du tout et là je
m'adresse au au partis majoritaire de
notre
majorité véritablement il faudra que
l'on puisse discuter que l'on puisse
avancer sur la prise en compte de la
véritable diversité de la majorité
politique les deux grands partis
politiques en place et leurs appareil
l'analyse que j'en fais ce sont quand
même des freins à de véritables avancées
vers une nécessaire transition alors
puisqu'on en est là que cette transition
est la transition
écologique au sens très large du terme
est une absolument nécessité j'en ai
l'intime conviction on se battra on se
battra pour cela maintenant que ce
scrutin est comme cela alors je parle
pour les écologistes à nous d'être
attractif auprès de la population à nous
de donner envie à des élus qu' à des
candidats qu'il soi urbains ou qu'il
soit ruraux de représenter notre notre
courant de pensée politique qui se voit
pas seul qui se voit dans le cadre d'une
majorité et c'est ainsi que l'on pourra
avancer une autre avancée nécessaire
dans le domaine de dans le dans le
domaine électoral sera la fin du cumul
des mandats parce qu'on en a besoin et
on a besoin de se reconnecter avec
l'opinion publique je vous
remercie merci la parole à Monsieur
Bruno
sidau oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
curieusement il y a un point qui n'a pas
été abordé sur cet article 2 je ne suis
pas juriste mais je livre mon analyse
sauf à modifier la Constitution
ou sauf à ce que les sages du Conseil
constitutionnel ne respecte pas la
Constitution dans leur décision ce qui
est
impensable le système binominal est
irréversible en ce sens que on nous
avons atteint l'oméga la parité si nous
votons cet article 2 et qu'on ne pourra
pas
régresser la seule alternative au
binominal puisque j'entendais monsieur
mzard faudra changer il y a plus qu'une
autre alternative c'est la
proportionnelle voilà je tenais à faire
remarquer ce point-l donc on est à un
moment important on va très loin et on
ne pourra pas revenir nous brûlons nos
vaisseaux et
avant de passer au vote je voulais le
faire remarquer à mes
collègues merci la parole à Monsieur
monsieur
roche qu'est-ce
queouz oui moi je voulais juste
reprendre ce que j'avais dit hier soir
c'est qu'à mon avis la barre de clivage
dans C assemblée ce n'est pas
entre les gens qui sont pour un scrutin
territorial il est entre ceux qui sont
pour un scrutin territorial et ceux qui
sont pour la proportionnel et le scrutin
pour la territoriale il dure depuis des
années cette bataille elle dure entre
nous depuis des années de avec les lut
territoriales et maintenant le binominal
et en se on dévie le le le fond du
problème donc moi je pense qu'il faut
sortir du blocage et dans avec les
ouvertures qui ont été faites hier par
Monsieur le Ministre sur le tunnel à +
30 -- 30 avec le 12 et demi pour le
droit de se représenter au 2è tour avec
l'assurance de laisser la
proportionnelle au-dessus dans les
communes de plus de 1000 habitants et je
vais demander aussi à monsieur le
ministre qu'il faut qu'on ait un autre
engagement c'est le découpage va se
faire par le Conseil d'État sur
proposition du ministre et après avoir
pris l'AVE des collectivité intéressé je
pense qu'il s'agit il y aura entre le
ministre et les conseillers généraux
intéressés un véritable débat et
qu'ensemble il y a un consensus qui se
dégage sur les territoires pour qu'on ne
puisse pas parler de charcutage
politique vous y avez tout intérêt et
nous aussi alors je cet engagement moi
je le demande pour que les choses se
passent de façon républicaine et je
terminerai en disant qu'aujourd'hui on
parle de la gouvernance de la voiture
des départements mais que notre
véritable souci c'est savoir si cette
voiture aura assez d'essence pour
continuer à
avancer merci mon cher collègue la
parole à Monsieur le
sererf et monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues je n'ai pas
d'autre ambition que de m'exprimer à
titre strictement personnel j'ai compris
depuis septembre 2011 que je siégeis
dans la minorité et que chers collègues
en face vous constituiez la majorité si
nous étions resté la majorité nous
aurions imposé la création du conseiller
territorial et j'y étais totalement
favorable vous êtes la majorité vous
imposez le binôme démocratiquement j'ai
pas grand chose à dire sur le reste le
travail de de de de d'amélioration du
texte le travail de concertation c'est
fait et c'est fait en profondeur en
commission des lois et en commission des
lois nous avons eu effectivement des
avancé que moi j'extrême j'estime
extrêmement importantes et sur
lesquelles le ministre s'est engagé et
moi je fais confiance à la parole du
ministre de la même manière que je n'ai
pas voté l'amendement de suppression de
l'article 2 il est bien évident que je
ne voterai pas contre cet article 2
merci mon cher collègue la parole à
Monsieur
Colomba monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues deux
choses on me dit que je suis en
avance en matière de
oui plusieurs me l'ont dit même le
parfois le rapporteur qui est très qui a
toujours été très très aimable et je
l'en remercie envers moi j'ai un peu
l'habitude en matière de en matière donc
de de collectivité
puisque déjà en
1993 les maires ruraux proposaient une
élection au suffrage universel direct
des délégués aux intercommunalités on
avait pas beaucoup de succès à
l'époque bon maintenant c'est devenu
quelque chose de parfait parfaitement
admis et qui ne pose aucun problème nous
sommes nous proposons aussi que le mode
de scrutin qui permet cette élection
commence à être appliquée dès la plus
petite
commune là on est un peu moins ambitieux
en matière de parité on me dit non c'est
c'est quand même un peu trop tôt très
bien on me dit
que le le mode de scrutin que que je
propose n'est n'est pas encore
applicable parce que l'intercommunalité
n'est pas parvenue à sa stabilité
définitive oui c'est parfaitement vrai
sauf que moi ce que je propose c'est de
faire le découpage sur la base des
intercommunalités et tout ça pourra se
perfectionner au gré effectivement de
l'avancement de l'avancement des choses
ce que ne pourra pas faire une fois que
ce mode de
scrutin sera sera voté qu'est-ce qui va
se passer ou il restera très longtemps
en place ou la majorité changeant comme
pour le conseiller territorial on va
tout effacer et on va
recommencer ce qui dans les deux cas de
de figure n'est pas vraiment
satisfaisant donc voilà
pourquoi je suis assez déçu de de ce qui
s'est passé mais c'est pas c'est pas
simplement parce que on n'est pas arrivé
à s'entendre sur sur ce point moi ce qui
me me déçoit le plus de des heures qu'
avons passé ensemble c'est
que c'est vraiment la manifestation de
ce qui est devenu notre parlementarisme
d'irrationalisé et que moi maintenant
j'appelle
lophilisé en
fait on ne sert à rien chers
collègues on se fait plaisir moi aussi
mais on sert à
rien non mais la logique on nous dit que
c'est la logique de la 5e République bon
c'est décidé c'est décidé c'est mis en
musique il y a ceux qui suivent et qui
soutiennent le
gouvernement quoi qu'ils fasse même s'il
pensent en le fort intérieur que il
ferait mieux de faire
autrement et puis bah il y a les autres
qui ma fois essayent de de batailler et
qui ne parviennent à
rien voilà donc ma fois c'est la logique
des institutions c'est vrai c'est vrai
moi je dis que on a beaucoup critiqué la
4e République qui est morte dans les
afres que vous savez mais les historiens
quand ils auront à se pencher sur ce cas
oui oui oui oui sur ce que sur la fin de
la 5e République ils se ils se poseront
la question de savoir ce que précisément
de 5e République il reste de
République
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur
Savin oui une toute petite intervention
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les débats de ce matin monsieur
le ministre on pour résultat d'abord
c'est une déception par rapport à aux
engagements ou au propos que vous avez
tenu hier soir qui laisser entendre
peut-être une ouverture une discussion
sur cet article 2 aucune ouverture donc
par rapport à vos déclarations d'hier
soir notamment sur je pense que beaucoup
d'entre nous surtous les bancs à gauche
comme à droite attendez peut-être aussi
un signe par rapport à l'amendement le
dernier amendement qui a été déposé
concernant cette proposition d'aller
vers le double objectif et la parité
mais aussi le la représentation des
territoires avec une élection sur les
cantons ruraux avec le binôme qui aurait
pu être voter un vote par binôme sur les
cantons ruraux et un vote à la
proportionnelle sur les territoires
urbains parce que quoi qu'on dise
aujourd'hui nos concitoyens dans
l'urbain ne connaissent pas leurs
conseillers généraux ne connaissent pas
les limites des territoires de leur
canton donc une élection à la
proportionnelle sur l'aspect urbain
était je pense une très bonne solution
et on gardait un vote sur des cantons
redécoupés en milieu rural avec
la possibilité du binôme ça aurait été
ça amené la possibilité d'assurer la
parité mais aussi une meilleure
représentation territoriale aucune
ouverture aucun signe et c'est très
dommage donc nous ne voterons pas je
voterai pas cet article
merci merci mon cher collègue la parole
à Monsieur
daller merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le Président vous êtes allé
tellement vite sur l'amendement 49
rectifié que je n'ai pas pu exprimer mon
point de vue euh je le fais maintenant
et pour que chacun soit bien conscient
de ce que nous allons voter parce que
moi je n'y comprends plus rien
l'amendement notre collègue sido qui
instaurit les section a été rejeté or
l'amendement 49 rectifié dit ajoute
derrière le mot candidat représentant
chacun l'une des sections du canton donc
moi je ne comprends rien alors je suis
pas par principe favorable à cette
affaire de section parce que étant donné
que le résultat sera comptabilisé sur le
canton et qu'on élit un binôme à partir
du moment où vous fléchez un candidat
sur une section du canton vous pourriez
avoir un candidat représentant une
section en étant minoritaire sur cette
section en terme de légitimité vous
avouerez que ça me semble assez étonnant
donc je pense que pour cela seulement
cette affaire de section n'est pas une
bonne idée mais en terme de cohérence du
texte franchement moi je n'y comprends
rien parce que il aurait fallu adopter
l'amendement sido pour que vous puissiez
effectivement adopter celui-là donc
voilà mes chers collègues ce que je
voulais vous dire pour que chacun soit
bien conscient de ce que nous nous
sommes en train de
faire merci mon cher collègue je passe
la parole à Madame David pour
explication de vote sur l'article
2 merci monsieur le Président pour
démarrer mon explication de vote je
dirais que nous avec mon groupe nous
allons voter donc contre cet article 2
en effet hier au soir dans le débat la
présidente de mon groupe a expliqué que
nous votions contre cet amendement les
amendements de suppression qui ont été
proposés parce que nous voulions que le
débat ait lieu et je trouve pour ma part
que le débat ce matin a été intéressant
hier au soir et ce matin pour les
explication il a été intéressant mais en
même temps il est décevant dans sa
conclusion puisque de tous les bancs
pratiquement de cette hémicycle des
propositions ont été faites pour
permettre une amélioration de cette
élection des conseillers départementaux
donc dont nous sommes bien d'accord
qu'il y a une nécessité à le rénover et
de ce point de vue je partage
complètement les propos de notre
collègue l'abbé quand il dit que cette
parité va permettre un renouveau dans
nos conseils généraux dans nos
département effectivement ce ce
renouveau sera effectif il est vrai avec
cette introduction du de de la parité
mais en même temps cela et vous l'avez
très bien dit mon cher collègue cela va
favoriser le bipartisme et il nous
semble que ce n'est pas bon pour la
démocratie que de se diriger vers cette
directionl nous vous avions nous-même
fait des proposition monsieur le
ministre pour une proposition donc d'une
introduction à la proportionnelle et
notre amendement avait l'avantage par
rapport à d'autres peut-être qui ont été
également présentés d'éviter quelques
écueils dont il a été beaucoup question
puisqu'il a été question sur certains
amendements de faire une proportionnelle
uniquement dans les cantons urbains et
laisser le mode de scrutin tel qu'il est
dans le le mode de scrutin tel qu'il est
dans les dans les s soi-disant enfin
plus ruraux et et et avec ça je ne peux
pas être d'accord mes chers collègues
car du coup la parité ne s'appliquerait
pas de manière égale sur l'ensemble du
territoire et donc c'est un des écueils
que nous que nous soulevions nous et et
du coup auquel nous répondions avec
notre amendement un autre écueil était
un clivage que vous alliez mettre en
œuvre entre les cantons ruraux et les
cantons urbains par les amendements que
vous présentiez notre amendement avait
l'avantage de faire une élection sur
chaque quanton avec une introduction à
la proportionnelle sur l'ensemble du
département et ça permettait au moins un
peu d'ailleurs dans le style de celui
que notre collègue lesped a présenté et
ça permettait l'introduction de 30 % de
proportionnel c'est un système qui est
déjà mis en œuvre en Allemagne alors
c'est c'est assez cocass finalement
parce qu'on on cite souvent l'Allemagne
en exemple lorsqu'il s'agit du travail
par exemple et pourtant la pauvreté est
en train d'augmenter en Allemagne
justement suite au système allemand de
travail qui est mis en place et là ce
système là mis en place en all Allemagne
qui pourtant répond à à de vraies
préoccupations et bien n'a pas n'a pas
convenu au ministres et à et à et à la
et à son groupe politique donc il y a un
bipartisme qui va s'installer un manque
de pluralité et ça ne peut être
acceptable pour mon groupe monsieur le
ministre c'est un rendez-vous manqué je
crois qu'on peut le dire nous avons
souhaité que le débat ait lieu
malheureusement malgré la qualité de ce
débat et malgré la qualité des échanges
vous n'avez pas voulu entendre les
différentes composantes de votre
majorité pour essayer d'améliorer ce
mode de scrutin nous ne pourrons donc
pas vous suivre sur l'adoption de cet
article merci ma cher collègue la parole
est à Monsieur patria pour explication
de
vote monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai le
sentiment comme notre ami Monsieur
Colomba que souvent nous pouvons ne
servir à rien ici c'est pour la raison
pour laquelle dans un débat certes
passionnant de plus passionné je me suis
abstenu d' d'intervenir
qui été conseiller général pendant plus
de 30 ans mais je trouve que dans ce
débat il y a beaucoup de cynisme il y a
beaucoup d'hypocrisie et il y a beaucoup
d'arrière-pensée d'abord nous taxer ici
majorité d'être des Ases du bistouri et
c'est un praticien qui parl je peux vous
dire que ce que j'ai connu comme
découpage depuis plus de 30 ans dans ce
pays pourrait me faire écrire quelques
pages assez drôle ou assez amusante je
me souviens d'un ancien ministre de
l'Intérieur qui siégeit sur nos bancs il
y a encore quelques mois ici qui a deux
fois s est repris pour essayer de
découper la circonscription dont j'étais
l'élu on comprenait pas que je la garde
à l'époque mais il a fallu trois fois
pour arriver Alce qu'en fin de compte
après avoir rajouté rajouté elle puisse
être gagnée je me souviens de ce
qu'avait dit son représentant il avait
dit mais nous sommes là dans ce
département monsieur pour faire que il y
ait 4 à un nous en voulons quatre nous
en laissons un c'était comme ça
l'arrièrepensée on voudrait aujourd'hui
n nous suspecter d'avoir les mêmes
arrièrepensées je peux vous dire que le
texte que nous allons ons voter
aujourd'hui l'amendement enfin l'article
2 pour lequel je vais voter il
correspond à définir demain pour nous
des départements que vous souhaitez tous
garder avec une France qui correspond à
ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui à ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui socialement à ce qu'elle
reprense aujourd'hui comme aspiration
j'entends la défense des territoires
comment peut-on opposer la défense des
territoires à la défense des urbains
est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui sont là
pour représenter des hectares et
d'autres des caches d'escalier non je
crois que les ce que les Français
attendent de nous c'est d'avoir des élus
certes en proximité certes qu'ils
connaissent beaucoup mieux que vous le
dites en territoire urbain parce que les
conseillers généraux qui travaillent en
territoir urbain savent se faire
connaître certes on connaît pas les
délimitations des cantons mais on
connaît le conseiller général ou la
conseillère générale quand elle
travaille alors c arrièrepensée de
charcuta je ne peux pas exister puisque
il y aura beaucoup d'équité au-delà de
la parité dans ce texte il n'y aura pas
plus de conseillers généraux urbains
qu'il aura de conseillers généraux
ruraux je prends l'exemple monsieur de
RACO d'un département que vous
connaissez
le département de la Côte d'Or 500000
habitants demain il y aura 23
conseillers généraux urbains et 23
conseillers généraux ruraux il y a
250000 habitants en ville et 250000
habitants à la campagne ne me dites pas
qu'un conseiller généraux qui seront
deux avec un canton qui fera 20000
habitants on ne peut pas quand on est
conseiller général avec les moyens
modernes même avec la mobilité plus
facile aujourd'hui 12 s'occuper d'un
canton dans lequel il y aura 10000
habitants c'est tellement plus facile
quand on est d'entrer en contact avec
ses électeurs avec ses habitants de
connaître les villages de connaître tous
les élus c'est tellement plus difficile
de monter toutes les cages d'escalier
dans les quartiers difficiles des villes
alors ne les opposons pas aujourd'hui et
je crois que ce je crois que ce texte
qui va mettre demain de l'égalité de la
proximité de la parité de la diversité
correspond à la France telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et pas celle dont vous rêvez
qui est celle d'il y a 200 ans que vous
n'avez jamais osé toucher quand un
conseiller général de Côte d'Or se fait
lire avec 464 voix certes lui les
weekends il a pas trop de mal occuper le
canton quand un conseiller général
urbain à 40000 habitants autour de
talent et de Fontaine les Dijon et que
le dimanche il doit aller voir tout le
monde les jeunes les personnes é le
sport il a beaucoup plus de difficulté
alors je crois qu'il y a des clivages de
faux clivages que vous défendez
aujourd'hui moi c'est au nom de
l'intérêt général c'est au nom de la
défense des habitants que je connais
dans mon territoire que je voterai
l'article
2 merci Monsieur patria la parole à
Monsieur lequesteur Alain andiani pour
explication de vote
oui monsieur le monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
moi je voudrais aussi faire un peu comme
Monsieur patria et insister sur ce qui
devrait nous rassembler plutôt que
d'épiloguer sans cesse sur ce qui
devrait nous diviser moi je vois au
moins trois principe qui devrait nous
rassembler le premier principe c'est
celui de la
légalité nous sommes tous évidemment des
partisans des défenseurs de la légalité
mais la légalité le Conseil
constitutionnel nous le dit le Conseil
d'État nous l'a rappelé c'est justement
l'obligation de redécouper des cantons
lorsque vous vous étiez majoritaire
lorsque vous vous avez voulu faire une
réforme aussi des territoires vous êtes
heurté à ce principe de l'égalité des
suffrages c'est un principe
constitutionnel vous deviez le respecter
nous devons le respecter nous devons
donc effectivement redécouper les
cantons est-ce que le redécoupage cette
fois-ci va utiliser des moyens
exceptionnel hors du commun bien non le
redécoupage c'est une affaire
réglementaire j'ai entendu hier
quelqu'un sur les bancs de l'opposition
dire pour la première fois le découpage
va être par décret non les rcoupages
relèvent toujours du domaine
réglementaire donc le domaine toujours
du domaine évidemment du
décret deè principe c'est le principe de
la
proximité mais pratiquement tous ceux
qui s'expriment disent et répètent nous
devons avoir un département proche de
nos électeurs et nos citoyens nous
sommes tous d'accord mais si vous êtes
pour ce principe alors écartez tout de
suite la proportionnelle si vous êtes
pour ce principe n'adoptez pas ou ne
proposez pas un mode de scrutin qui
ferait du département une sorte de mini
région le mode de scrutin conditionne le
comportement et conditionne évidemment
l'attitude des élus si vous voulez des
élus de proximité ne faites pas
évidemment la proportionnal qui a
d'autres vertus mais qui a certainement
pas celle-ci et puis le troisème
principe c'est évidemment le principe de
la parité j'ai entendu avec beaucoup
d'intérêt monsieur sidau tout à l'heure
nous mettre en garde d'une façon quand
même absolument exceptionnelle en nous
disant oui mais regardez si vous vous
avancez sur ce terrainl alors nous ne
pourrons plus revenir sur la parité oui
mais monsieur sidau vous voulez vraiment
revenir sur la parité la parité est
également un principe constitutionnel la
parité est dans la Constitution nous
devons tendre vers la parité donc nous
devons nous réjouir d'un scrutin qui va
nous permettre d'assurer enfin dans les
départements la parité et je conclurai
en disant ceci en disant peut-être deux
choses d'ailleurs la première c'est
est-ce que nous voulons un avenir au
département oui alors modernisons le
département nous savons que si nous ne
modernisons pas le département la voix
du département deviendra de plus en plus
faible dans ce pays et puis le trisème
point et je sais que vous y êtes
sensible à quoi servons-nous à quoi sert
le Sénat mais c'est à vous de donner la
réponse si vous demain ou ce soir ou je
ne sais dans combien d'heures vous de
nouveau montrez que finalement ce que le
Sénat fait ne sert à rien alors vous
posez une question institutionnelle de
grand ampleur alors moi j'appelle votre
sagesse je vous demande de bien
réfléchir faites en Ste que le Sénat
puisse peser dans le débat d'aujourd'hui
et dans les débats de
demain merci mon cher collègue la parole
à Monsieur
keltenbach
encore je vais être rapide puis que il y
a beaucoup d'impatience sur les bans de
la droite c'est un bon un bon mode de
scrutin que ce scrutin organisé par
l'article 2 c'est une création c'est
vrai il n'existe nul part ailleurs mais
c'est un mode de scrutin ingénieux
ingénieux qui permet de répondre au
besoins de proximité et à la nécessité
de la parité j'ai entendu beaucoup de
critique sur ce mode de scrutin j'ai
entendu 10 propositions alternatives
mais sur ce sujet comme bien d'autres
lorsqu'il y a trop plein de solutions
alternatives c'est bien la preuve
qu'aucune ne s'impose et qu'ine fin et
qu'ine finé il faut se rallier à ce mode
de scrutin qui va répondre aux
contraintes qui ont été bien posées dans
le débat la proximité je l'ai dit la
parité je l'ai dit mais également
l'égalité dans le scrutin alors quels
sont les reproches qui sont euh portés
contre ce mode de scrutin il y aurait
moins de proximité pourquoi parce que
les cont eururau vont être plus
importants c'est vrai mais allons-nous
continuer à vivre avec des cantons de
1000 habitants 1500 habitants est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est
ça dérange ça dérange le principe le
principe constitutionnel d'égalité
devant le scrutin et il est normal que
dans le même département il y ait autant
de différence dans la taille des cantons
cela donne des Conseillers généraux élus
avec 1000 personnes d'un côté et 40000
de l'autre c'est bien sûr inacceptable
donc des cantons un peu plus grands ne
nuirons pas la proximité et se d'utant
qu'il y aura deux élus dans ces cantons
un peu plus grands deux élus qui
pourront tout à fait travailler main
dans la main pour défendre les intérêts
de leurs canton et de leur département
donc sur la proximité je crois que la
réponse est la bonne réponse les cantons
seront un peu plus grands certes mais ça
sera plus juste et surtout il y aura
deux élus dans ces cantons sur la parité
tout a été dit ça va être une vraie
révolution il y aura en effet demain
dans les conseils départementaux autant
de femmes que d'hommes et je crois que
nous pouvons être fiier de cette avancée
démocratique dans le sens de l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes et en
effet comme l'a justement fait valoir
monsieur Sid ce sera irréversible et
c'est tant mieux c'est le sens de
l'histoire on ne pourra pas revenir en
arrière et puis sur l'égalité dans mon
scrutin là aussi il fallait y venir le
découpage était indispensable vous
l'auriez effectuer dans le cadre du
Conseil Territorial nous allons le faire
dans le cadre de ces nouveaux cantons
voilà je dois dire que d'ailleurs le
conseil territorial a été bien peu
défendu sur les bancs de la droite et
j'ai bien le sentiment que sa
suppression suscite beaucoup
d'indignation à droite mais une
indignation qui n'a égale que votre
satisfaction action de voir cet élu
hybride définitivement sortir du paysage
maintenant que nous savons que ce mode
de scrutin sera adopté bon j'ai compris
qu'ici l'article 2 avait peu de chance
de passer mais nous savons qu'à la fin
l'assemblée adoptera ce mode de scrutin
la vraie question est d'améliorer les
dispositions qui vont l'entourer de
façon à ce que les problématiques porté
par les élus locaux soi bien pris en
compte et là j'ai été complètement
rassuré par les déclarations du ministre
d'ailleurs un amendement du groupe
socialiste défend cette idée d'un tunnel
plus large à plus ou moins 30 % cela
permettra de répondre avec plus de
souplesse aux contraintes du découpage
l'article 23 tel qu'il a été modifié le
permet déjà mais à TR exceptionnelle
avec ce nouveau tunnel à plus ou moins
30 % nous aurons vraiment la possibilité
d'avoir un découpage plus souple qui
prendra mieux en compte les réalités
territoriales et ça sera une très très
bonne chose je voudrais également
rassurer les élus d'Europe écologie des
vers je crois que ils ont trouvé avec
les socialistes un partenaire qui je
crois les respectent et on l'a vu à
l'occasion des élections sénatorial
législative vous n'avez pas été brimé
par par par vos partenaires il il y a
aucune raison il y a aucune raison qu'il
que ça soit différent pour les élections
pour les élections pour les élections
départementales les socialistes ont
toujours les socialistes ont toujours
rassemblé dans des plaises plaise à la
droite et enfin pour conclure pour
conclure l'enjeu l'enjeu est vraiment de
savoir quel rôle doit jouer le Sénat en
effet cet article 2 peut être peut être
rejeté ici mais mais réfléchissons bien
au sens d'un nouveau rejet de l'ensemble
du texte par le Sénat voulez-vous encore
en commission mixte paritaire que le
Sénat soit absent et que l'assemblée
fasse seule la loi c'est cette question
là qui est posée cette questionl est
posée il faut je crois que le Sénat est
toute sa place et que un texte sort de
nos débats un texte qui ne soit pas
parfait mais qui permette au moins sur
des points sur lesquels il y a accord
comme le plus ou moins 30 % comme le
seuil de qualification pour le second
tour que nous soyons en mesure de
défendre ces idées en commission mixte
paritaire et c'est pourquoi j'espère que
la sagesse l'emportera et que malgré un
rejet probable sur l'article 2 sur
l'ensemble du texte nous pourrons
aboutir à un accord qui permette des
avancé dans le sens de l'intérêt gén de
la déf des territoires que nous
représentons ici au Sénat
merci merci mon cher collègue la parole
à Monsieur
Dubois dernier orateur
inscritur monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le
précédent gouvernement avait fait un
choix il avait fait un choix il avait
décidé
effectivement de créer un nouvel élu le
conseiller territorial et et le texte
prévoyait que ce conseiller territorial
à la fois conseiller de la région et du
département aurait la possibilité si les
collectivités ont décidé après un
référendum dans les départements
éventuellement de regrouper ces
territoires il laissait donc avec un élu
qui travaillait dans ces deux
collectivités le choix à moyen terme de
réorganiser les collectivités de
proximité vous vous vous annoncez vous
annoncez très officiellement que vous
voulez garder le département vous
l'annoncer mais vous ne le pensez pas
vous êtes je dirais dans une hypocrisie
que je considère d'État une hypocrisie
d'État pourquoi pourquoi mes chers
collègues pourquoi pourquoi les
collectivités départemental vous le
savez sont confrontés à trois défis un
défi opérationnel un défi financier un
défi de gouvernance le défi opérationnel
he quand on regarde l'acte 3 de la
décentralisation tout aux régions rien
au département quand on regarde la
fiscalité et les recettes pour les
départements pas grand-chose pour les
départements et d'ailleurs un peu moins
encore pour les départements ruraux et
finalement pas de solution et enfin on
arrive au troème point la gouvernance
et la gouvernance on est là tout à fait
dans une véritable
hypocrisie la proximité s terminée alors
que le Conseil Général et le département
étai une collectivité où la proximité
était au cœur de ces dispositifs prier
élément deè é deè élément déséquilibre
déséquilibre majeur effectivement avec
le système d'élection puisque les
territoires ruraux qui avaient
effectivement un vrai besoins de
département et de conseil général vont
se trouver avec ce système électoral
finalementa en terme de déséquilibre par
rapport à la ville et puis enfin la
gouvernance mettre en place sur le même
territoire deux élus on sait très bien
que ce duo qui sera finalement lors de
l'élection tout à fait rassemblée
rentrera dans un duel dès qu'il aura été
élu ça veut donc dire
finalement la collectivité
départementale que vous dites vouloir
soutenir que vous dites vouloir
sauvegarder et bien toutes les actions
que vous mettez en œuvre sont des
actions pour le voir mourir à petit feu
ce département auquel nous sommes
attachés particulièrement sur les
territoires ruraux voilà les raisons
pour lesquelles monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je voter contre
l'article
mero explication de vote à Monsieur
guerot monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
essayer d'être rapide je voudrais
simplement vous dire combien j'approuve
le travail qui peut être fait pour aller
vers plus de parité en tout cas pour
créer cette égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes ça me paraît être essentiel
et c'est sur le plan républicain une
démarche plus qu'utile forcément
nécessaire mais c'est pas le sujet qui
nous qui nous qui m'interpelle
aujourd'hui c'est que je me mets à la
place de nos concitoyens nos concitoyens
considèrent que nous représentants de la
politique nous sommes relativement
nombreux on va leur donner l'image
aujourd'hui non pas d'une simplification
mais d'une complexification on donnera
l'image quelque part d'avoir fait de la
boutique interne avec aujourd'hui quand
vous êtes dans une intercommunalité vous
allez avoir deux personnes qui vont se
présenter qui vont vous dire nous sommes
vos conseillers départementaux et à côté
il viendra les conseillers
communautaires qui seront également
présents mais aussi les adjoints maire
et puis aussi les conseillers municipaux
et puis aussi le sénateur le député et
cetera et je trouve que cette cela ne
donne pas une très bonne image de la
politique et nous devons forcément nous
poser cette question comment faire
évoluer les choses en répondant
d'avantage à l'aspiration de nos
concitoyens qui à mon avis ne s'y
retrouveront pas dans ce qui est ce
projet tel qu'il est présenté
aujourd'hui merci mon chers collègue
donc j'ai de nouveaux inscrits madame
procasscia vous avez la parole pour
explication de vote sur article 2 merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je suis conseiller général j'ai
été élu au scrutin majoritaire et je
dois dire que je tiens au scrutin
majoritaire parce que c'est celui qui
donne l'onction des citoyens c'est celui
par lequel les femmes en particulier
sont reconnues et on nous accuse pas
d'avoir été élu uniquement sur une liste
et pas en entre nom donc le scrutin
majoritaire est quelque chose
d'important et je suis contente que ce
scrutin demeure par contre pourquoi je
suis contre le binôme je suis contre le
binôme non pas parce que c'est un homme
et une femme mais je suis contre le
binôme parce qu'il va mettre fin à la
diversité politique dans les
départements c'est très simple comment
voulez-vous que des nonincrits que des
indépendants qui représentent un canton
puissent avoir dorénavant deux
indépendants sur un grand canton de
40000 ou de 50000 habitants c'est
impossible comment voulez-vous que dans
des un départ ement comme le mien comme
le nôtre puisqu'il y a le président
Favier ici présent là où il y avait un
socialiste au milieu de trois cantons
communistes un um au milieu de trois
cantons PS on puisse continuer à avoir
cette diversité politique il y en aura
deux sur des cantons plus grands c'est
absolument impossible on est en train de
tuer la diversité politique et c'est ça
l'objectif recherché à mon avis à
l'avance et non pas les femmes quand on
sait en plus ce nous est remonté par nos
collègues que ce sont les sections
socialistes qui ont présenté qui ont
fait remonter les premiers découpages
dans notre département et que ces
sections socialistes ont fait en sorte
que ceux qui sont leurs ennemis sur le
plan politique c'est-à-dire l'UMP et le
Parti communiste perdent des cantons
dans notre département comment
voulez-vous que l'on puisse sifier donc
moi je voterai par conviction contre cet
amendement d'autant plus que quand on
nous menace de faire trancher par
l'Assemblée nationale par des députés
qui en 2006 200007 ont bien voté le
suppléent aux élections cantonales mais
se sont refusé à appliquer eux-mêmes
cette parité et pour l'instant hormis le
président de la République il y a que
des députés qui ne peuvent être élus
qu'avec un suppléant homme et bien moi
je n'ai pas confiance et je voterai
contre
merci ma chère collègue la parole à
Monsieur Mercier
essayez donc de devenir conseiller
général vous verrez qu c'est difficile
et il y a très longtemps je suis
conseiller général je suis très attaché
à ce mandat et j'ai cependant bien
conscience du caractère un peu décalé de
ce que je vais dire maintenant moi je
regrette qu'on commence par une loi
électoral sans s'être posé la question
que fait-on du département comment
organisons-nous le territoire de la
République demain alors on peut faire
cette on peut faire cette critique
souvent et je l'accepte parfaitement
mais on avait peut-être l'occasion de se
poser la question dans le bon sens
plutôt que de voir s'opposer j'étais
très triste ce matin et d'écouter les
oppositions rural urbain ça tient pas de
bout je siège dans un conseil général
qu'on présente général comme urbain mais
qui est aussi rural et je crois qu' est
conseiller élu en métropole à Lyon ils
se font connaître très bien parce que il
y a quelques années ave monsieur
chevedement nous avons redécoupé Lyon et
ça se passe très bien chacun est élu
d'un quartier historique et ça marche
mais c'est pas là la question la
question c'est est-ce que le département
dans la France d'aujourd'hui tel qu'el
tel qu'elle est qu'elle évolue est
nécessaire utile ou s'il faut faire
autrement et si on se pose pas cette
question là on peut difficilement
répondre à la question quel mode
électoral il y a des territoires où le
département est absolument indispensable
parce que c'est le lieu de la
mutualisation les collectivités de r pas
a Dr inférieur mais plus territorial ell
sont trop faibles pas assez riches pas
assez puissantes en hommes et en femme
et il faut organiser le territoire
mutualiser et ce département il est là
pour ça et puis il y a les grandes
agglomérations ou s'il y a pas de
département c'est pas une catastrophe et
on pourrait avoir une
organisation
différente il y a aucune nécessité
d'avoir une
uniformité sur tout le territoire de la
République on peut aujourd'hui tenir
compte des diversité et c'est peut-être
ce qu'il faudrait faire et la loi
électorale que sur laquelle on est en
train de disc
elle présente des inconvénients des
avantages comme tout lo électoral et
toujours ceux qui la font voter sont
battus à l'élection d'après donc il faut
pas moi je dirais pas du tout vous
faites ça vous faites ça mais bien sûr
mais mais ça vous est arrivé ça nous est
arrivé et et on sait bien donc moi je
vais pas dire au gouvernement vous
faites une loi parce que vous allez
gagner les actions avec ça vous pouvez
parfaitement les perdre mais si on c'est
peut-être ce qui arrivera peut-être ce
qui arrivera pas ça dépendra aussi de
notre capacité à être bon
les citoyens choisissent les bons ils
écartent les mauvais et ils ont toujours
raison c'est comme ça la République et
il a rien d'autre à dire mais moi je
pense qu'on aurait pu faire une autre
loi électorale pas opposer ruraux urbain
dire oui le département est très
nécessaire dans sur tel type de
territoire et il faut garder la
proximité parce que
en restant sur des grands principes on
aboutit parfois au résultat contraire de
celui qu'on voudrait le système avec
deux candidats binôe
électoral vous essayez de résoudre deux
questions différentes celle de la parité
vous la résolvez très bien on fera pas
mieux mais il y a une chose que vous
résolvez moins bien en ne voulant pas
modifier le nombre d'élus c'est que vous
éloignez des conseillers généraux et des
électeurs dans un département comme le
mien si on y touche pas n€ 75000
habitants par
canton c'est c'est cela la moyenne dans
un territoire pour trouver les 75000
habitants bah dans le nord-ouest du
département faudra faire 80
km je reconnais que Monsieur patria que
grâce aux voitures électriques de demain
si on fait quelques barrages on pourra
en effet veiller à ce que le conseiller
général puisse aller d'un coin à l'autre
mais sinon ça marchera pas et et les
gens se connaîtront plus et je pense
donc qu'on aurait été bien inspirés tous
on étant un peu modeste de s'interroger
sur que fait-on du département demain
euh où est-ce qu'il faut le garder sous
quelle forme pas partout pareil avant de
dire quelle loi électorale on allait
voter cette précipitation voter une loi
électorale pour moi ça me chiffonne un
peu surtout que quand on regarde la loi
qui suit celle sur l'acte 3 de la
décentralisation on voit bien que la
compétence première et qui viendra
presqueunique du département ce seront
les les affaires social et que là aussi
il faudra bien traiter les gens un peu
partout de la même façon une personne
handicapée qu'elle habite dans la riège
ou à Paris c'est une personne handicapée
qui vit dans la République française
elle a les mêmes droits elle doit avoir
les mêmes moyens de vivre avec son
handicap et et et compenser ce qui veut
donc dire que ce sera de moins en moins
une collectivité territoriale de plus en
plus une collectivité et qui sera
chargée d'assurer un certain nombre de
prestations sociales et ça devrait
vraiment nous faire réfléchir sur le
rôle du département je regrette qu'on
l'ai pas fait et qu'on ait voulu passer
d'abord sur la loi électorale avant de
se les vraies questions de
fond merci mon cher collègue la parole à
Monsieur Mirassou pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur clair parce qu'eectivement au
moment de se déterminer la question mite
posé si savoir si le pluralisme la
parité et la proximité
était à l'occasion de ce vote ble la
réponse apparemment est non puisque ce
là même qui
préconisait à travers le scrutin
proportionnel là le pluralisme de fait
s'éloigner de la proximité et donc au
bout du bout par rapport à cet article à
cet article 2 et bien nous allons avoir
un moyen terme qui de notre point de vue
nous sommes non seulement acceptable
mais souhaitable parce que en alliant le
concept de la parité il maintient avec
force celui de la proximité et malgré
les options pessimistes qui ont été
évoquées sur les Rand du MP qui prévoit
en avance le disfonctionnement du binom
c'est faire peu de cas du fait que ce
binô sera désigné par le biais du
suffrage universel et donc par
définition il il y aura une forme de
contractualisation
entre le fonctionnement du binô les
objectifs recherchés et les électeurs
qui leuront porté au niveau des
territoires
concernés vous avez également fait un
procès à cet article 2 et d'une manière
plus générale à ce projet de loi en
expliquant que on allait avoir
disparaître les cantons ruraux ou en
tout cas allait-il être singulièrement
affaibli
dois-je vous rappeler mes chers
collègues qu'en 10 ans à coup de RGPP en
supprimant une palanquée de brigade de
gendarmerie de bureaux de poste de
tribunaux et j'enasse vous avez
sérieusement initié ce que maintenant
vous condamnez par
anticipation donc donc oui mais le
constat au moment où on parle il est
pasant et il est le vôtre sagissant des
tribunaux et tout ce que je viens
d'évoquer donc moi je suis d'accord avec
la définition qui a été évoquée
s'agissant du département tournons-nous
plutôt vers l'avenir un département
garant de la proximité un département
garant de la solidarité entre les
institution elle-même mais également
entre les différentes composantes de ces
départements s'agissant de ses
habitantes et habitants et je reprends
ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
excellemment par François patria il n'y
a pas les habitants d'un département
du rural et ceux des cages d'escalier
l'ambition c'est de faire en sorte qu'en
se tournant vers l'institution modernisé
et bien on puisse concilier l'intérêt
confondu des uns et des autres c'est la
raison pour laquelle parce que ce projet
présente à travers cet article de
l'ambition et en tout cas une vision
d'avenir et bien bien entendu le groupe
socialiste non seulement le votera avec
conviction avec force mais vous incite à
revoir votre
position merci mon cher collègue ces 17
explications de vote ont éclairé le
Sénat je vais passer la parole à
Monsieur le
Ministre alors non pas tout à fait
éclairé le Sénat monsieur longuer vous
avez la parole mais ça soort dou je
l'avis pas eu
oui merci monsieur le Président de votre
mensétude monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues j'ai voté avec enthousiasme
l'amendement
49 rectifié tel qu'il a été adopté par
la commission parce qu'il me conforte
dans l'idée qu'on ne peut pas voter
l'article 2 et que le système binominal
est un système absurde pour une raison
d'ailleurs très simple vous allez
territorialiser avec cet
amendement l'amendement 49 rectifier
vous allez territorialiser chacun des
élus en leur attribuant une section
quelle sera la situation de l'élu issu
d'une section au sein de laquelle il
aura été notoirement minoritaire par
l'addition des résultats dans des
bureaux de vote alors que son adversaire
lui malheureusement élu parce battu
parce que son son conjoint en quelque
sorte son
cocandidat ne lui aura l'aura desservi
dans une autre section lui sera
majoritaire on est dans un système
parfaitement absurde et ce 49 rectifié
que vous avez adopté avec tranquillité
sirénité j'ai voté à l'immense mérite de
montrer que vous allez créer des élus
qui seront pas représentatif des
territoires qu'ils prétendent
représenter merci Monsieur long monsieur
le rapporteur vous avez la
parole point d'histoire monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre cette
affaire de section a été longuement
débatue au sein de la commission des
lois et je rappellerai au commissaire
des lois que comme rapporteur j'étais
hostile aux amendements prévoyant des
sections mais
malheureusement je ne suis que
rapporteur et la Commission et la
Commission et la Commission a voté ses
amendements je ne puis donc que
rapporter l'avis de la
commission merci monsieur le rapporteur
je passe la parole à Monsieur le
Ministre de
l'Intérieur et monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs euh
rapidement il n'y a pas de suspense
sur le vote qui va avoir lieu et sur le
rejet de l'article 2 la M si vous me
permettez est d'une certaine manière
dite sur ce
point j'avais eu l'occasion plusieurs
reprises hier je le redis ici
aujourd'hui mais très
tranquillement qu'il y avait l'occasion
d'un rendez-vous et ce rende
il va être manqué une nouvelle fois
pourtant pourtant moi j'ai le
sentiment depuis les débats de hier que
la cause du scrutin
binominal a
avancé malgré les propos compris qui
viennent d'être rappelés par Monsieur
longu d'abord pour une raison et vous le
savez c'est que ce scrutin binominal va
s'appliquer
puisque effectivement l'Assemblée
nationale le
votera donc chacun
l'intègre
deuxièmement et j'en fais pas un
argument juridique desilleur politique
mais un
constat il n'y a pas
d'alternative à ce scrutin non pas en
soi mais à travers les débats qui ont eu
lieu il n'y a pas de majorité ni à
l'Assemblée ni au Sénat pourr
de liste il n a pas de majorité pour un
scrutin mixte qui oppose l'urbain au
rural ça été fort bien démontré c'est
pas dingue réité n'y a pas cette
majorité et donc pas
dingue il n a non il y a de débats il y
a de débats dis oui mais distingue ça
oppose à l'évidence perception qu'on a
de la représentation François patria l'
a très bien démontré il y a un instant
entre le rural et l'urbain et très
honnêtement peut comprendre la proximité
dans des cantons de 1000 habitants mais
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de vous le dire
ici élu pour pour ce qui me concerne
d'un
territoire urbain les deux conseillers
généraux dont l'un est sénateur ici
l'autre aujourd'hui maire d'EV sont
connus de la population
donc et un élu il doit être
connu quand quelqu'un travaille connaî
se fait élire et dans la proximité
surtout sur les compétences du Conseil
général il est connu et puis il peut pas
y avoir de majorité pour le statu parce
que le statut d'abord soit il nexiste
pas parce que le Conseil Territorial a
été adopté et de toute façon les règles
constitutionnelles empêchent statut et à
l'évidence ici au Sénat il n a pas
encore de majorité pour le scrutin
binominal et donc vous allez vous en
remett d'une certaine
manière à l'Assemblée nationale pour
trancher définitivement cette question
même s'il y aura encore débat ici au
Sénat après la commission mixte
paritaire je l'ai pas oublié donc d'une
certain c'est pour ça que je dis
président gin que cela
progresse et j'ai fait des propositions
hier et entendu tout à l'heure je
n'avais pas fait état d'ouverture mais
enfin pas sur
effectivement des propositions qui
dénaturaient le texte du Gouvernement
mais les propositions que j'ai fait hier
je rappelle qu'elle demeure elle elles
demeureront bien
évidemment monsieur Kaltenbach l'a
rappelé il y a un instant et je l'en
remercie c'est élargir le tunnel avec
les risques
constitutionnel que j'ai déjà évoqué
mais de 20 à 30 + 20 30 en nous appuyant
notamment sur le travail et du Sénat et
de l'Assemblée concernant les critères
qui vont présider au découpage et tous
les éléments que nous avons
progressivement rassemblés en écoutant
les élus notamment qui représentent ces
territoires montre qu'on peut
effectivement mettre en œuvre ce nouveau
tunnel de + 30-- 30 vous allez en
discuter à l'article 23 et donc ça sera
l'occasion là aussi d'avancer
progressivement même s'il n'y a plus
l'article 2 j'ai pris un autre
engagement plus difficile évidemment
pour des raisons politiques mais enfin
j'ai pris cet engagement également au
nom du gouvernement concernant le seuil
pour le second tour
12,5 pour le
découpage c'est vrai que c'est un
découpage général d'une très grande
ampleur l'ampleur
totale il y a deux garanties qui
existent déjà c'est la vie évidemment de
chaque département et puis c'est
évidemment la viis du Conseil d'État qui
va être sollicité par décret pour chaque
département et je me suis engagé ici
même mon le
sénateur un travail avec les présidents
de Conseils Généraux avec les grands
élus pour faire en sorte à partir de ce
découpage que on garde à l'esprit
l'intérêt général découpage est toujours
extrêmement difficile nous le savons
bien sur le plan électoral il peut y
avoir de toute façon des procès justifié
ou non sur les conséquences de ce
découpage moi je pense un peu comme le
min ministre Mercier de toute façon ça
ne change pas la vie des électeurs en
revanche ce qui me paraît important
c'est que l'intérêt général c'est-à-dire
garder la proximité et mettre en œuvre
la parité ça c'est un élément important
je sa pas quel quels seront les
résultats des prochaines échéances
électoral pour nos collectivités pour
ces collectivités mais en tout cas là il
y aura un changement le conseil
constitutionnel peut
revenir
sur ce type de décision il a accepté
d'ailleurs dans sa décision de 2010 sur
le conseil territorial la suppression
d'un mode de scrutin régional
proportionnel et paritaire au profit
d'un mode de scrutin uniquement
majoritaire et non paritaire je parle
des régions donc le Conseil
constitutionnel peut évoluer dans ce
sens mais je pense que politiquement
c'est peut-être aussi ce que vous aviez
en tête monsieur sido politiquement il
sera très difficile de revenir sur la
parité et puis j'ai pris enfin un autre
engagement c'est d'ailleurs le vote du
Sénat en première lecture concernant les
1000 habitants pour le seuil de la
proportionnelle ses engagements il
restent il demeurent est évident je le
redis encore on verra le vote final il
est important par rapport à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'un texte soit adopté avec
un certain nombre d'élément que j'ai
rappelé il y a un instant parce que si
le texte de l'Assemblée du du Sénat
pardon avec les éléments que j'ai
rappelé qui ont d'ailleurs été adoptés
par la commission des lois ne sont pas
dans un nouveau texte sur lequel
l'Assemblée nationale aurait à discuter
vous reconnaîtrez à à ce moment-là en
tout cas que le poids la force et les
propositions du Sénat ne pourrai pas
être prise en compte donc les choses
avancent
avec la particularité et
l'expérience du Sénat moi je considère
que ce scrutin est un scrutin utile et
juste et qu'il va progressivement
s'imposer dans les mœurs il va s'imposer
sur le plan politique parce que il
permet de conforter le département il
permet cette représentation territoriale
qui tient compte à la fois de la
population et les territoires de la
démographie et de la réalité de la
diversité de ces territoires et il
permet évidemment la parité il restera
j'en suis sûr l'un d'entre vous l'a dit
comme un scrutin qui peut changer en
profondeur qui peut révolutionner la
représentation politique et je ne doute
pas un seul instant que chacun d'entre
vous a bien en tête ce que je viens de
vous dire
merci merci monsieur le ministre je vais
mettre au
voix l'article numéro 2 je suis saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe UMP il va donc être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions fixé
par l'article 56 du
règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront secrétaire un bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
remettront un bulletin bleu ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir remettront un
bulletin rouge le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques
instants le scrutin est
ouvert
scrutin est clos j'invite Mesdames et
Messieurs les secrétaires à procéder au
dépouillement de ce
scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 108 sur
l'article 2 du projet de loi relatif à
l'élection des conseillers
départementaux des conseillers
municipaux et des conseillers
intercommunaux non nombre de votants
346 nombre de suffrages exprimés
322 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés
162 pour l'adoption
137 contre
185 le Sénat n'a pas adopté l'article
2 mes chers collègues la non adoption de
l'article 2 rend sans objet un certain
nombre d'articles du texte la connexion
juridique est directe évidente et
incontestable avec les articles 5 8 9 10
11 et 12 ainsi qu'avec les alinéas 1 à
15 et 22 de l'article 13 en ce qui
concerne l'article 3 s'il est
politiquement lié à l'article 2 il n'est
en revanche pas il est en revanche
juridiquement
distinct en tout état de cause merci
monsieur le Président de la Commission
en tout état de cause aucun de ces
articles ne tombe seul l'adoption d'un
amendement de suppression peut les faire
disparaître du
texte donc nous allons continuer nos
travaux et le débat et je voudrais
saluer Monsieur Hervé poer sénateur du
pas decalais qui vient de nous rejoindre
dans l'hémicycle pour la première fois
il vient d'être installé ce matin et je
lui souhaite la bienvenue au
Sénat
nous en sommes à l'article 3 et je suis
saisi de trois amendements identiques de
suppression l'amendement numéro 22
rectifié présenté par Monsieur yest vous
avez la parole mon cher
collègue pardon monsieur le Président
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur
yest évidemment l'article 3 qui diminue
de moitié le nombre des cantons était
quand même même si effectivement il ne
disparaît pas était lié à au vote sur
l'article 2 on on comprendrait pas qu'on
maintienne l'article 3 dans la mesure où
l'article 2 ne serait pas voté puisqu'on
diminue de moitié le nombre de cantons
c'est forcément lié donc c'était le sens
de l'amendement qui avait sa logique par
rapport aux amendements de suppression à
l'article
2 merci mon chers collègues euh
amendement numéro 148 présenté par
monsieur le président zooketo
il est défendu monsieur il est défendu
et l'amendement 208 rectifié présenté
par Monsieur Colomba qu'on fait merci je
vais je vais demander l'avis de la
commission monsieur le
rapporteur c'est favorable sur ces trois
amendements
identiques sur quelques cas de
figure le rapporteur était défavorable
et la Commission s'est déclaré
favorable merci avis du gouvernement
monsieur le
ministre avis défavorable je vais mettre
au voix ces trois amendements et
notamment le
ou monsieur de monolf pour explication
de vote oui merci Monsieur président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
pour explication de
vote il y a je crois une raison tout à
fait légitime on l'a vu au cours de
l'examen de l'article 2 pour aboutir
coupage le gouvernement a proposé un
nouveau mode de scrutin qui n'a pas été
adopté à cet instant néanmoins il n'y a
aucune légitimité à diminminuer par de
le nombre de cantons et en partant du
nombre
historique non encore une fois pourquoi
part-ons du nombre historique de canton
pour les diminuer par deux ça fait
perdurer des inégalités qui existent
historiquement mais à partir du moment
on a supprimer même le Conseil Général
quelle est la raison juridique au regard
du principe d'égalité devant les
suffrages qui justifie dès lors qu'on
inv vote un nouveau mode de scrutin que
l'on parle du nombre actuel de de de
canton concrètement à l' exemple éé cité
à l'instant dans certains départements
nous aurons des besoins de 80000
électeurs pour élire un binôme si si le
binôme persiste dans d'autres
départements nous aurons 6000 besoin de
6000 électeurs donc concrètement ces
inégalité historique qui pouvait se
justifier regarder l'histoire et la
jurisprudence du Conseil d'État veiller
à chaque fois qu'il y a un redécoupage à
ce qu'on les diminue ne se justifie plus
dès lors que l'on a vote à nouveau mode
de scrutin encore une fois pourquoi
faudra-t-il 6000 électeurs dans un
département pour élure un binôme et dans
d'autres 60000 électeurs on ne peut pas
comprendre la raison qui qui consiste à
partir du nombre actuel de Canton et est
diminué par deux je ne vois aucune
raison alors le ministre nous répondra
peut-être que il était extrêmement
difficile d'aboutir à une moyenne
nationale sinon dans certains
départements il n'y aurait que quatre ou
cinq élus peut peut-être mais on pouvait
très bien créer des strates de
population et aboutir à une certaine
égalité en terme de nombre d'électeurs
par département en tous les cas je pense
que cette diminution par deux consistant
à partir du nombre actuel de canton fait
perdurer des inégalité et pose un vrai
problème au regard de du principe
d'égalité qui a été suffisamment invoqué
ce matin et je pense que le conseilel
trouvera redire c'est la raison pour
laquelle je voterai la suppression de
l'article 3 euh encore une fois qui fait
part du des inégalités historiques qui
ne se justifi plus aujourd'hui dès lors
qu'on a vote à nouveau mote de scrutin
merci merci mon cher collègue je vais
mettre au voix ces trois amendement de
suppression qui ont reçu un avis
favorable de la commission et un avis
défavorable du rapporteur de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour leur
adoption adopté qui qui est
contre ils sont adoptés les amendements
de suppression sont
adoptés et l'article 3 est supprimé nous
passons à l'article 4 avec un amendement
246 rectifié présenté par Monsieur dem
goolfier je peux pas faire
plus simplement un amendement de
conséquence qui propose la suppression
de l'article 4 merci avis de la comm
rapporteur sur le 246
rectifié avis du
gouvernement défavorable également je
mets au voie le 246 rectifié avec de
avis défavorables qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté 4 amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le 74 présenté
par le groupe communiste par Monsieur
Favier
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues cet
amendement que nous avions déjà déposé
en première lecture à succité avec
d'autres amendements allant dans le même
sens des débats qui ont chacun s'en
souvient Transcend de nos rangs vous
nous avveit dit monsieur le ministre que
cette question n'était pas à l'ordre du
jour de ce projet de loi qu'un autre
viendra en son temps sur la question du
cumul des mandats mais on voit bien que
ce temps semble reculer chaque jour un
peu plus aussi donc en reposant une
nouvelle fois cette question nous
souhaitons poursuivre nos débats en
effet lorsque l'on parle du cumule des
mandats on entend surtout parler d'en
limiter le nombre aussi importante
qu'elle soit cette limite n'est pas à
notre avis la seule question la durée
des mandats nous semble aussi donc être
devoir poser on nous dira que limité
comme nous le proposons à de mandatures
la possibilité d'exercer un mandat est
trop court surtout au niveau
départemental comme en toute chose les
réformes posent problème car elles
remettent en cause existant les
habitudes prises d'autant qu'elle mettra
aussi en cause quelques situations en
effet si chacun sait que ce n'est pas
avec un bilan que l'on gagne une
élection il n'empêche qu'un bon bilan
évidemment ça aide mais avec cet
amendement nous souhaitons surtout
affirmer l'idée donc en limitant donc à
à deux mandats donc à 12 ans malgré tout
nous voulons surtout affirmer donc
l'idée que le mandat de conseiller
départemental comme n'importe quel autre
mandat ne doit pas devenir évidemment un
métier aussi réduire la durée de mandat
permet à un autre élu d'intégrer une
telle période élective au sein d'un
parcours professionnel diverse
cela permettrait aussi on le sait par
ailleurs un renouvellement plus fréquent
du personnel politique diversifierait
aussi la sociologie des élus et limitait
nous semble-t-il aussi l'inertie et
parfois le
clientélisme aussi la politique se
conçoit trop souvent pour certains comme
une carrière construite à partir de
cumul de mandat de façon successive dans
le temps ce cumule induit une coupure
entre des professionnels de la politique
et des profanes qui seraient eux les
citoyens aussi nous pensons qu'il nous
faut garder de nous faut nous garder de
la professionnalisation que le meilleur
permettre à un élu de vivre son action
politique servir l'intérêt général au
service de ses concitoyens acquérir des
compétences dans la gestion des affaires
publ en se consacrant à son mandat
parfois à plein tempemps et c'est donc
dans cette perspective donc que nous
inscrivons cet amendement donc de
limitation à 12 ans donc de la durée
donc d'exercice d' mandat départemental
merci Monsieur Favier restez au micro
s'il vous plaît à moins que vous
considériez ce qui doit être le cas que
le 75 est défendu ou le suivant il est
défendu à mesure o propose
éventuellement trois madame lipi il est
défendu votre amendement
123 il est défendu et l'amendement 210
présenté par Monsieur mard il va être
défendu merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues il y a deux sortes d'avancées
démocratiques les vraies et puis celles
qui ne sont que de l'affichage pour
faire plaisir aux militants et donc par
cet amendement euh nous
proposons de limiter à trois mandats
successifs consécutifs euh la
possibilité donc d'être élu dans un
conseil
départemental ça on peut dire que c'est
une avancée euh démocratique euh
d'ailleurs je pense
que nous aurons ce même débat bientôt
concernant euh euh les communes il y a
de grandes communes où il est pas
logique de de rester pendant des
décennies je pense par exemple à Lille
ou à d'autres exemples que nous
pourrions mettre en exerg
donc
donc je crois que nous faisons là une
proposition dans le cadre de cette
réforme départementale que vous vous
avez annoncé encore il y a quelques
minutes comme pérenne historique je
crois que pour que ce soit vraiment
historique il faut qu'elle soit
accompagnée d'un certain nombre d'autres
avancées et c'est l'objet de cet
amendement qui correspond d'ailleurs à
des propositions de loi que nous avons
déposé depuis plusieurs mois dans un
souci de faire avancer la démocratie
dans notre pays je pense à certaines
inigibilités à certaines
incompatibilités à certains cumuls
horizontaux sur lequel de grands partis
sont aujourd'hui strictement si
merci monsieur le Président mzard
Monsieur le Rapporteur avis de la
commission sur ces quatre amendements
s'il vous
plaît la commission monsieur le
Président a rendu un avis
défavorable mais je pense pour une
partie des membres de la commission
essentiellement parce qu'on s'est dit
qu'on allait retrouver ce débat à
l'occasion d'un texte prochain merci
Monsieur le Ministre même avis je vais
donc mettre au voix ces amendements je
pense qu'il y a pas de demande
d'explication de vote pour aucun d'entre
eux amendement 74 de Monsieur Favier
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
son adoption qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté amendement 75 même vote même vote
amendement 123 même vote même vote
amendement 210 rectifié de président
mzard qui est pour son adoption qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté nous passons
à l'amendement 159 rectifié Bés par
Monsieur
Nami monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mon la question que je me pose
c'est d'essayer de faire en sorte qu'il
a le maximum de participants le plus
grand nombre de participants au débats
citoyens et la date du mois de mars qui
est reTue depuis longtemps pour les
élections régionales et départementales
n'est pas forcément l'on voit bien
aujourd'hui la date la plus propice pour
permettre à nos nos électeurs d'être sur
le terrain et de nous écouter je propose
donc que nos dates soi a reporter au
mois de juin simplement dans un souci de
meilleure démocratie merci mon cher
collègue avis de la commission avis
défavorable avis du ministre défavorable
pas de demande d'explication de vote je
mets au voix l'amendement 159 rectifié
bis avec deux avis défvorable qui est
pour son adoption qui est contre il
n'est pas adopté je mets au voix
l'article 4 qui est pour son
adoption qui est
contre il y a pas de vote contre
l'article le 4 est adopté nous passons à
l'article 5 je suis saisi de trois
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune trois amendement de
suppression amendement 23 rectifié de
Monsieur yest
oui cétait un amendement de cohérence
puisque on parlait de binô et donc
puisque le binô n'existe plus
réjouissons-nous merci donc merci idem
pour monsieur le président zoqueto
monsieur Dubois le
149 évidemment et le 2 rectifie de
Monsieur Coloma même chose ok avis de la
commission avis favorable avis du
ministre favorable je mets au voix
l'amendement 23 rectifié bis 23 rectifié
excusez-moi de Monsieur yest amendement
de suppression qui est pour son
adoption l'amendement est adopté les
trois amendements sont
adoptés et l'article est
supprimé donc les autres amendements
tombent nous après l'article 5 à
l'amendement 46 rectifié présenté par
Monsieur
point quelqu'un
du c'est pas l'amendement du groupe umep
personne ne le défend il monsieur de
Mongolfier voilà jeis retirer cet
amendement puisque contenu des votes
précédents son objet tombe un peu merci
merci donc il
est après l'article 5 amendement 84
rectifié présenté par Monsieur guerot
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement a pour objet d'aménager un
référendum local afin de permettre aux
habitants d'un département d'exprimer
leur volonté de rejoindre ou non une
autre région que celle dont ce
département fait actuellement partie son
insertion dans ce projet de loi
électorale nous ayant été suggéré le 28
février dernier par Monsieur suur
rapporteur de la commission des lois
avec l'approbation de Madame Lagarde
desess saau cet amendement a toute sa
place dans ce projet de loi relatif aux
collectivités territoriales pour être le
plus complet possible ce projet
d'article qui vise à modifier l'article
l41 2211 du Code Général des
Collectivités Territoriales calque la
plupart des futures dispositions des
deux projets de loi sur le référendum
d'initiative partagé voté au Sénat le 28
février dernier ceci afin d'y annoncer
d'y énoncer les conditions et le
processus de tenue du référendum local
par analogie avec ce qui avait été
annoncé et énoncé au titre du référendum
d'initiative partagé voilà donc cette
l'objet de ce référendum merci mon cher
merci mon cher collègue avis de la
commission défavorable avis du
gouvernement défavorable monsieur le
Président de la Commission vous avez la
parole merci Monsieur le le Président je
voulais dire à notre collègue monsieur
guerot qu'en effet cet amendement a déjà
été
présenté lors de notre débat sur la loi
organique portant application de
l'article 11 de la
Constitution il n'a pas été possible de
le retenir tout simplement parce que cet
article 11 de la
Constitution porte dans ses derniers
alinéas sur le référendum d'initiative
partagé qui implique obligatoirement
l'intervention du Parlement
j'avais dit que il serait tout à fait
possible de le déposer à la faveur d'un
texte ultérieur et j'avais cité deux
textes c'est vrai celui-ci c'est
parfaitement exact et puis le futur
texte sur la
décentralisation simplement entetemps je
me suis rendu compte mon cher collègue
qu'il est difficile et même impossible
de l'inscrire dans ce texte puisque
votre amendement implique la région
or dans le présent texte il n'y a aucune
disposition relative à la région puisque
le texte porte sur les départements les
communes et
l'intercommunalité je crois donc que
votre
amendement
don sera tout à fait à sa place dans
l'examen du futur projet de loi sur le
nouvel acte de la
décentralisation donc c'est pas une fin
de non recevoir je crois que c'est un
sujet auquel un certain nombre de nos
collègues sont très légitimement
attachés notamment dans l'ouest de la
France mais non exclusivement mais
simplement ce serait un cavalier ici
comme celui t étaé sur l'article 11 sur
le le projet de loi organique relatif à
l'article 11 de la Constitution il sera
impossible de dire s'agissant de la
future loi sur la décentralisation que
ce serait hors sujet merci monsieur leés
président de la commission madame
Lipietz pour
expliqu Monsieur guerot Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE oui nous venons de nous
entretenir extrêmement rapidement étant
donné donc la réponse de monsieur le
Président de la Commission et donc de
l'engagement qui serait pris de le
présenter dans le cadre du projet de loi
de Madame Lebranchu sur la
décentralisation nous retirons donc cet
amendement merci l'amendement est retiré
nous passons à l'article 5 bis avec qure
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune l'amendement 212
rectifié présenté par Monsieur le
Président
mesard merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
il s'agit encore une fois d'un
amendement qui a pour but d'aller vers
des avancées démocratiques tout à fait
nécessaires dans la période
actuelle et nous avons proposé que les
durées
d'inégibilité qui touche les préfets
depuis nombre d'années soit étendu au
sous-préfet secrétaires généraux
directeur de cabinet de préfet
sous-préfet chargé de mission auprès
d'un préfet ainsi que les secrétaires en
chef de sous-préfecture en disant que
dans le département où ils exercent ou
ont exercé leur fonction il faut qu'il y
ait un délai de carence de 3 ans ce qui
est le cas pour les préfets actuellement
avant de pouvoir être candidat donc nous
rempl façon le délai de 6 mois par un
délai de 3 ans ça paraît tout à fait
légitime parce que c'est en fonction je
dirais de l'égalité entre les candidats
qu'il est nécessaire de proposer ce type
de disposition vous verrez que dans un
certain nombre par un certain nombre
d'autres textes nous viserons car nous
avons déposé un certain nombre de
propositions de loi en ce sens pour
faire vraiment un vrai ménage
démocratique des dispositions qui
touchent
les assistants les collaborateurs de
cabinet parce que nous savons très bien
ce qu'il en est des conséquences
malheureuses que cela peut entraîner
merci monsieur le Président mzard votre
amendement de repli est
défendu monsieur le Président mard
est-ce que votre amendement de repli est
défendu merci beaucoup amendement 10
rectifier bis présenté par Monsieur
Nami monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mais mon amendement va un peu
dans le sens celui présenté par Monsieur
mzard mais de façon un peu différente
euh actuellement les membres de cabinet
de président de conseil générauxx ou
président de conseil régionaux n'ont pas
le droit de se présenter aux élections
départementales et régionales cette
inélégibilité semble tout à fait normal
du point de vue déontologique mon
amendement vise à étendre cette
inélégibilité au collaborateurs de
groupe d'élus certaines en effet
certaines collectivités recrut des
collaborateurs de groupe dont en
pratique les fonctions sont proches de
celles des collaborateurs de cabinet
donc mon amendement
souhaiterait qu'on applique les mêmes
règles pour tout le monde que que la
règle initiale soit étendue au membres
des cabinets dans un souci de d'éthique
et de transparence de la vie politique
merci mon cher collègue monsieur le
Président mzard le 214 rectifié pour les
collaborateurs de parlementairire
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la totalité
des membres de mon groupe a souhaité que
nous déposions cet amendement qui
correspond là aussi à des proposition de
loi que nous avons déposé nous
considérons qu'il est indispensable si
l'on veut vraiment changer les mœurs
démocratiques dans notre pays d'éviter
que les professionnel de la politique
euh développe une action qui est
contraire déjà à l'égalité entre les
candidats et puis qui est extrêmement
dangereuse pour le processus
démocratique car la la vraie réalité
aujourd'hui le vrai danger il est là
hein on nous parle à longueur de journée
à longueur de semaine à longueur de mois
du problème du cumul des mandats mais le
vrai problème démocratique il est plus
là dans ces euh dans ces bureaucraties
dans ces technocraties euh politiciennes
rémunérées qu'ailleurs et nous proposons
donc que ou ça c'est c'est c'est du
mauvais esprit monsieur le
les lesab nous proposons que les
collaborateurs de députés de sénateurs
rémunérés par les crédits alloués à
cette fin par l'Assemblée nationale ou
le Sénat dans le département où a été
élu leur employeurs qui exercent ou ont
exercé leur fonction depuis moins de 3
ans ne puissent être candidat aux
élections départementales avec là aussi
un délai de carence de 3 ans parce que
nous voyons l'évolution aujourd'hui
l'évolution très clair de gens qui
immédiatement sont ont accès à ces
métiers là et qui par le biais des
partis surtout des plus grands partis
d'ailleurs passent directement
oui enfin Monsieur monsieur mon cher
collègue ce genre de de disgression ne
me paraît pas ni respectueuse des autres
parti que nous sommes hein car nous nous
qualifierz nous dire que que nous ne
sommes pas de vrai parti je crois que ce
débat là nous pourrons l'avoir
prochainement et je crois que vous
pourriez vous passer de ce genre de
discrétion assez
habituelle et je crois que je représente
ici au moins autant que vous un vrai
parti qui n'a pas de leçons à recevoir
par rapport à son histoire par rapport à
ses élus que ce soit hier aujourd'hui et
je l'espère
demain donc cet amendement vise à
étendre les cas d'inégibilité au conseil
départemental aux collaborateurs
parlementaires merci monsieur le
Président mzard avis de la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur Commission a rendu un avis
défavorable monsieur le Président sur
ses amendements pour partie parce que
elle a observé que l'Assemblée nationale
dans un article 5 bis avait déjà relevé
de 6 mois à 1 an la durée
d'inéligibilité pour un certain nombre
de personnes visées par les amendements
qui sont proposés donc il nous a semblé
que c'était peut-être pas nécessaire
d'aller à 3 ans et secondement parce
que si le problème existe le débat sera
à un moment donné général soit sur le
cumul de mandat soit sur un autre texte
et qu'on ne pense pas que ce soit par
petite touche comme ça qu'on peut
réformer ce probl
merci monsieur le rapporteur avis du
gouvernement
oui monsieur le Président mesames et
messieurs les sénateurs je je partage
l'avis du
rapporteur bon il va y avoir forcément
je dis au président
mesard qui représente un territoire une
grande formation politique ancrée dans
l'histoire de notre pays euh durable je
n'en doute pas un seul instant mais il
va falloir
aborder toutes ces questionsl au-elà de
ce que l'Assemblée nationale a déjà pu
intégrer avec une vision
d'ensemble voilà pour le rejet de
l'article 2 du projet de loi défendu par
Manuel Vals le ministre de l'Intérieur
et qui visait à mettre en place un
scrutin binominal paritaire une
innovation qui devait permettre d'élire
un binôme homme-femm par canton et qui
aurait dû entrer en vigueur lors des
prochaines élections cantonales en 2015
vous pourrez évidment revoir ce rejet à
tout instant sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée à tous
sur notre
chaîne